The joe rogan experience.
Fuck it. We'll just splice it in
commercials later. Todd glass.
There's no reason to get all crazy.
Oh, there you go. My headphones.
Old School. Old School. That's not
even old school. That's new school.
We were just talking about this
tee shirt that I'm wearing,
which is a firm Cap City Comedy Club
in Austin and one of the great American
comedy clubs like without a doubt,
one of the top three four
clubs in the whole country.
You know we're talking about like places
that have you not hearing yourself a
little hard. Oh it's too high.
Too Low. Oh he can to low.
Who is in here that like beautiful.
That's so much work. So hard.
People always say like
when I do UFC broadcast,
like why are you fucking
screaming all the time?
You were scream on TV and like if
she there, you can't hear anything.
Like people are so loud, like there's
nothing like one of those environments.
It's so fucking loud. So when we're
talking before the beginning of the show,
I have to talk louder. I can't
even hear what the fuck I'm saying.
You can't even though, you know, it's
hard to imagine. Okay. I know that every,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
I've got lost already.
But, uh, what I wanted
to talk to you about is,
I know that you had a hand in designing
one of the other great comedy clubs in
the country. You had a hand in designing
helium, didn't you? I did. And,
and you know what? I give
him a lot of credit. Um,
what's so funny, I just saw that
fake head. Oh, this the aliens.
Funny to turn to them dope,
isn't it?
I can hold a conversation that cat
is making me a, he's making me, um,
another thing, a Zombie.
That guy's Badass. Oh,
by the way. Uh, so I should
say my opinion means anything.
Cause we talked about
it a little off there.
This is why I don't want to
insult the other podcast.
It's not something they care about,
you know, let me look at it that way.
But like this is the coolest studio I've
ever seen. Like you took a lot of time,
like creatively to make this a cool
space. The brick wall, the red curtains,
the black ceiling, the lights with the
like stars in them, the lava lamps,
the rocks. It's like, why
fucking nut, right? Yeah. Well,
I wanted to do something that would
make me comfortable. Like if the,
if I don't think it, yeah,
if you have an opera,
I'm very childish and with
what I like, you know, and uh,
like aliens and fucking big foot and
the Werewolf in the front of the place.
I'm very childish, but I
don't, you know, if I'm in a,
in an environment that's not like me,
if I'm in a like a clean,
sterile environment, they'll always
be like a little bit of hesitation.
Even if it's a fraction, a little
something that keeps, wants to,
it makes you want to
keep it, you know, PC or,
or not be so honest or whatever.
Office environments I think ultimately
are that they like hypnotized people.
I think just the idea
that you're in an office,
all of a sudden everybody
becomes something that
they're not everybody puts on
this bullshit attitude. They
all have this, uh, this,
this weird way of behaving.
No one swears, no one talks
about sex. And then you know,
you're not even supposed to
bring up religion or politics.
Supposed to like everything's supposed
to be like super fake when you're dealing
with customers, super
flat, no personality,
and really ultimately make it look
super predictable for the person you're
talking to.
Like you're gonna follow a very strict
pattern of thinking and behaving.
You're a gentleman at Biz in
doing business. Well, uh, yeah.
That's why even then when I see
managers offices, like I won't say who,
but like you, this is your way
to express yourself creatively.
Which people then like if I walk into
a manager's office and he gets it
creatively and um, I don't
know him that well, I go,
I give them some points for
that. Oh, this guy gets it right.
This manager could have anything he want.
It's not like he,
it looked like hertz and we are
still behind his back. Go, what?
This is what he wanted. Like this is like
if you had to go, ah, fuck it. Look at me.
I work at Hertz. Look at my office.
He goes, I want that. Look. Anyway,
that story is available in store. Okay.
I did sort of don't give a fuck though.
Right? It's something that they
don't put self analyze myself.
All I'm worried about my,
that story was horrible.
I don't even remember what the story
is. That's where I'm at. I swear to God,
I swear to God that's how much I get lost.
Wow.
And now I'm going to just talk
about wherever I'm at. Dude,
we got bookmarks for you. Do you?
Don't worry. You don't have to worry.
We'll always refresh you and let you
know what we're talking about in every
conversation. We're ready.
Hi Person Professional.
When it comes to be and
I were excellent at it.
Did you ask me a question that we're
talking about helium? Actually,
we were talking about you having a say
in the design because somebody had told
me like before I'd ever worked there,
it's like the best club in the country.
They were like, this place is perfect.
It's like everything you want to club,
low ceilings. People are packed in tight.
A great neighborhood. It's really cool.
Neighborhood is a lot of their bars and
jazz clubs and like there's a lot of
funky shit in that area and that
club is just perfectly set up.
And then they told me that you
had a hand in designing it. Yeah,
mark called me and he uh, uh, through uh,
Lewis Lee or somebody from
Minneapolis and they said,
you're opening up a club and uh, you
know, um, is that the guy from acme?
He's the one. Zach, well,
back to backtrack a little,
which I thought was cool that
mark even knew to do. I go,
how did you know to call Lewis Lee?
He also called him.
Louis basically taught him how to
run a club. Well Acmes another exam.
I've never worked at acme
but I was there recently.
I was hanging out with the arch barker
and he was working there and it's a
fucking amazing place. It is. It's
perfect. And all comedians like it.
Mark did the guy who opened up helium,
I'm like, well how'd you know to pick him?
Like, how'd you know acne? He goes,
oh, I went to a comedy festival as a,
as a non club owner,
just a guy who thinks he wants to open
up a club and he has every comedian what
their favorite club was. He goes, who?
You're attacking me a lot. He goes,
that sounds like a guide. Want to talk
to? I go, that's so brilliant. He goes,
it's just common sense. I go, yeah, but
it's every, most people don't have it.
It's like we were talking about cops the
other day and I love cobb's cobb's in
San Francisco. I started at the old
cobb's, which is a really tiny place.
It don't mention cops. To me it was
this kid and you know how many people,
no matter what you're talking about,
hey,
don't mention anybody I can mention around
you and then you have to ask them why
and then it becomes about
that. That's really what it
is. Let's guys are annoying.
That's exactly what it is.
They turn it into something about them.
It doesn't have to do with
what you're about to say.
That's to do with their personal trickled.
Did I count it every seat in the room.
He's 180 seats.
She told me 270 sheet
rooms or stealing 10 seats.
Oh God.
Those guys are the worst.
Those guys that are getting
robbed everywhere they go.
And I'm not saying that people haven't
been robbed before. Legitimize.
It's when it happens,
obviously come on every story.
These people have so many stories.
It's like I've taught class hasn't been
ripped off. Why have you been ripped out?
What the fuck is going on that you keep
getting ripped off by who you mentioned?
Oh, Vinnie APAM squats off.
Well, there's a show for him.
There had to be at least a thousand
people. It gives me a check, 80 bucks.
Fuck that shit. And there's certain guys
that just have an animosity towards, uh,
club owners.
There's a almost like a natural animosity
because of the fact that like in the
beginning, they didn't want to
have anything to do with you.
You were real like rejected girl,
you know,
that isn't mature yet. You know, get
real emotional about it and very upset.
And then when the guy comes around,
you're like,
where the fuck were you when I was 18
you know, people get crazy. All right.
I think comedians get that way too.
We'll need.
Then in the beginning they're fucking
terrible. So nobody wants to use you.
You can't work anywhere and you have
to slowly work your way into a position
where someone's actually willing to pay
you to have their customers hear you
talk. And that's a really kind
of a special relationship.
And the beginning part is so bad
that we developed this weird sort of
contentious relationship
sometimes with club owners.
I think that's like really ridiculous.
You know? I think you're right.
I think you're right. And again,
because I'm overly paranoid,
we're not saying that certain people
haven't legitimately maybe been ripped off
shore. And when that happens,
that sucks. What we're saying,
like a lot of that animosity comes
from exactly what you just said.
It's like you, maybe you were bad.
Then maybe you know, maybe this,
maybe that may be, you know, but
they're not all bad people. Well,
a lot of good ones.
It took me a while to get the respect
of the people that I came up with in
Boston,
like the clubs in Boston.
I was headlining on the road before
I was headlining back in Boston again
because they saw me when I was terrible.
I mean,
they saw me as an open mic or I should
never been allowed to go on stage.
So when,
so when you seen someone just fucking
stink it up hardcore for like, you know,
a year or two in the beginning
of their career, it's just,
it just makes sense that you
wouldn't want and you're like,
five years later you're like,
Chrissy, man, I'm not buying it.
This guy's gotta be still terrible.
You know,
I saw him when he was an open miker and
every comedian sorta says that they have
to like leave your town and get success
elsewhere and then they respect it and
recognize it. But if they see
you when you suck in their mind,
you suck. Like Pete, it's
really hard for people to adapt.
It's works that way with athletics
too, with fighting. It works that way.
And these guys that believe
that this guy can't beat them.
There's no way that guy could be
me. My like, I just you like, it's
craziness.
It's a crazy way of thinking.
But they know back when the guys sucked
and they refuse to admit that people can
figure things out that people can improve.
Yeah. I even have that
happen, but I try not to like,
I'll think I'll think of somebody
the way I thought about them.
You know somebody, there's a
comedian wanted to, Oh, a Jew,
a middle in Philadelphia and
I, and I really think of,
well, you're probably like,
oh wait, I haven't seen him in a while.
And then I take the time, I'm like,
oh my God, I just got stuck in this
mindset, but at least I got out of it.
I love the comedian that it's about,
don't fucking find it. If it's not useful.
You know what you but don't be so sure
you might, okay. I'm very sorry it's you,
but don't be so sure there's somebody
on that has to be me. I'm from Philly.
I worked with Todd and Philly. Wasn't
he? Just say my name. Give me a plug.
People are too damn sensitive about
a people's assessments of them.
As long as those assessments are polite,
you shouldn't take it to
fucking personally. You can
learn from those things.
Yeah. I had a comedian
once. You know what?
I'm glad that I just luckily
wasn't stupid because he goes,
I could have easily been offended,
but early in my career, he goes, well,
hung out during the day and then he goes,
he said this affectionately,
I remember it. I was like 23 maybe 24 he
goes, he goes, you're funny hanging out.
He goes, what are you doing
up there on stage? You know?
Like I knew he was fucking right
and he knew I could handle it.
You know? He said something, he goes,
that's what you want to be doing. But I,
but I remember thinking I could have
easily been like fucked up. Right.
That's my story.
You know what my story could have been
then this fucking idiot tells me I'm fun
me offstage, but I'm not. Fuck you.
I was doing better than you every night
when she might've been because he was
bad, but whatever. He was honest with
me. And, um, instead the story is,
thank you,
I appreciate it.
He said that it made me
consciously tried to change that
there was a guy that said something
to me when we were both starting out
together. We had been both doing
it about six months and, uh,
I was still like,
I still had my foot in another world.
I was still teaching martial
arts since I was still competing.
And I was really confused. And
he said to me, goes, you know,
he was being a Dick, totally
being a dick. He goes,
you started off pretty funny man,
but you, uh, you lost promise.
He seemed to be repeating yourself
and it's just like you, uh, I dunno.
It seems like you've lost
momentum. And I was like, wow.
And I didn't argue with them. That
was the weird part. I didn't like,
fuck you bitch. You know, there
was none of that. I just went, wow,
I got to agree with you. Like I'm
not really paying attention a comic.
And Open Miker that I worked with
that you know, we would, you know,
we were all like sort of competitive
young guys and going to these school,
I try to be, I have some camaraderie, but
there was always a glad we were young,
we were retarded, we didn't know
how to communicate with each other.
We didn't know how to be honest and
express ourselves and we were insecure as
fuck. We're trying to be a standup
Comedians, most insecure world,
probably in show business.
He created all yourself and he said
something that was totally true and I
remember it. It's tall,
it's stung for sure,
but it made me make a clear decision to,
to just abandon the other, to
[inaudible] to completely remove myself,
quit my job, just get, get jobs,
like paying for things just
because that's what one thing is.
One Guy said that it helped me a lot.
Like I could say like he was being a
dick when he was doing it and I'm sure he
was,
I'm sure he's trying to hurt my feelings,
but he was right and because he was right,
it was really beneficial.
It was really important and
it was really important,
like for me as a comedian to mate,
first of all,
to be aware that that this
has to apply this way.
Although it's like very difficult to do,
especially emotionally,
it's very difficult to accept criticism.
It's very difficult to see people
see yourself as other people see you,
but it's so fucking important. If you
can't do that, like you're, you're gonna,
you're gonna never continue to grow.
You're going to hit a
rough spot and then boom,
you're going to tail
spin and then that's it.
Yeah. You see that a lot. Fuck
yeah, you do. It's funny people too.
That's what's a shame. Like it's not
funny, but they get caught in this,
something goes wrong. Yeah. Or
like, and like we said before,
the ones that I remember, comedians
that had fucked this business attitudes.
I'm not kidding.
Like now of course then it seemed like
they had been doing comedy a long time,
but like eight years into the business,
right. Fuck this. Fuck this business.
We're two years in. I remember it
comedian having a joke, like, hey, here.
Really? That's so silly that
man. Well, it's the same thing.
It's like a rejected boy or a rejected
girl. Rejected young person, I should say.
It doesn't have emotional maturity and
they get angry. That's really what it is.
Like that rejection sometimes is the best
fucking thing that can ever happen to
you. Like it might feel like shit, but
you'll figure that out because of it.
You're either going to quit,
are you going to figure it out?
You're going to have a new inspiration
suit so that you know what? Um,
I would never want to own a club.
When I complain about club owners,
I've realized I'm not changing this.
Does it seem like I'm changing
the subject? Not at all.
Not at all. You're right.
I'm going.
I know exactly what you got because I
do make fun of the bad clubs and I do.
I spend a lot of time making fun of the
bag clubs and they should be made fun of.
Some of them have fucking,
they're horrible, but I
also defend the good clubs.
I wouldn't want to own a good club.
You know why?
Imagine all the fucking whack a doodle
comedians fucking bothering them and
getting mad at them unnecessarily. Like,
you know, not all of them. I wasn't.
I was, I remember thank
God and I did a lot wrong,
but I always knew that like I, I forgot,
I completely forgot what I was talking.
We're talking about clubs and like getting
along with clubs and I never got mad
at club owners over the years
when a club wouldn't use me.
You know what all at all I liked
is when they told this story,
and I can think of a specific club that
said this. I wasn't what they wanted,
but they said, you know,
he was nice and he,
the staff liked them because
it's just not my thing.
But he tried to point out that I
was at decent guy and you know what?
I accepted it. I was like,
I remember someone was like,
fuck him. I go, no, no, no.
He has a right,
he can't love every comedian,
but at least he told that's not
the story I could have told.
I could have been like,
oh yeah, I could have
been that same story could have been
even though the guy did it right and he
tried to, I could have been like, fuck
him. You know what he tells my manager,
the staff flight to the Fox that
supposed to mean, you know what I mean?
Like flipping it around negative.
Totally. Yeah. So it was so,
and there was a few clubs over the years
that wouldn't hire me and guess what?
Some Jew now and uh, I, you know,
I didn't want to be that person. I'll fuck
that club. They will now. They want you.
So what do you want to teach
them a lesson? Love the fact
that they exist. I mean,
one of the best things about being a
comedian is the ability to work in clubs.
I do some larger spots now and I,
but I still do like the ice house.
Like I deal with the Ice House on a lot
of Wednesday nights and it's only like
150 people or 190 people or something
like that. It's fucking amazing.
It's a magical room. I mean
it's, it's magical. It's tight.
The ice house is dark and it's got 50
fucking years of laughs burned into it,
you know, I mean that's
legit. That place. If, uh,
an area or a space can encode a memory,
can somehow or another capture a memory.
Like if you go to,
my dad went to Gettysburg and he
said when he was there, he felt sad.
He said it really was a overwhelming
feeling of sadness. He goes,
it was really hard to describe.
He's not an airy fairy sort
of a woo woo kind of a guy.
And when he said that about Gettysburg,
he's an architect and I said that
about Gettysburg. He was like,
he was just something about
it. It just didn't, just,
you could feel it in the air.
I really believe that. I believe a club
like the laugh stop in, uh, in Houston.
Did you ever work at that? Stop that
place, that place you walked in,
you said you felt it in your fingers.
You're like, Whoa, this place is on fire.
Mark Babbitt is the reason that club used
to have a great reputation. And I love,
let me tell you something I don't wish
anybody ill on. I don't wish anybody ever,
I don't care what they do.
I do not wish anybody ill.
But I do wish that your
empire would fall apart.
It doesn't mean anyone would be
sick or homeless or, but you're,
I do wish your empire would fall apart.
Like it did not realizing Mark
Babbitt was why you had it.
They never knew that he
was the soul of that place.
So when he left it went down hill
and they have no idea to this day,
do you think they have the intelligence
to go, hey, what happened there?
We made a huge mistake. We had a
manager who fucking basically gave them,
you know, we didn't know how
important he was. We fired them.
And the business slowly closed.
No,
they're just telling some other's
bullshit story. Was there a matter of,
I don't know,
there was some sort of a legal matter.
I don't want to mention what might or
might not have happened because honestly
I've just rumors.
I guess what I heard from fucking
Ralphie minor knew it that fuck I totally
turned on him. He was a, you know,
a guy who really loved comedy and
that's a historic fucking club.
Maybe Bill Hicks recorded, didn't Bill
Hicks one of his standup specials there?
Saint Man, I think, I'm not
sure, but I know that um,
one of his early special said sure. But
I wasn't positive. I think it was there.
Um, and that's, that used to be where
the, the, the annex was, you know,
we're s Kinison started out and Hick
started out like you would walk into that
last stop in river oaks.
There was two laptops.
It was the one and then they moved it.
When they moved it,
that's when things started getting
squirrelly. But the original one,
you would walk into that place and you
would feel the fucking energy that has
been pumped out into that room.
Like these people have like years
and years, a fucking hysterical
gold laughter. Like impregnates the
walls. You want to hear new place.
Didn't have that. Do you want to
hear what you're talking about?
But someone took advantage of this and
works at for them when they sell homes,
I swear to God, this is
what a girl told me. It'll,
it goes back to exactly what
we're talking about. She goes,
you want to know my line?
I say, when I'm selling,
someone's selling some of the house.
She goes, I say of House has sold this.
I don't you feel like this has a good one.
And she goes, most people like, oh yeah.
Especially if they liked the house,
but she's full of shit. She's lying.
She's just saying that.
But every half else,
that's such a good line that people go,
yeah, I it does have a good soul and, but,
but she's working on something that
does exist as we're talking about.
Cause I agree. There's no way those
laughters it's not just in our head,
that's something there, that's some
energy when a room has had that much,
you know, not out that much
soul. You know, I don't,
I mean it sounds like horse
shit. Makes Sense. Sure.
Uh, any reasonable scientist would
tell us it's horse shit. Oh really?
But maybe,
maybe it does for us symbolically because
you know what that like when I walk
into the punchline,
Atlanta de Jesus Christ,
I mean that place has been around forever.
It's a fucking masterfully bill club.
Another one perfect comedy club.
And you see those pictures of the wall
like Richard Jenny when he was like 30,
you're like, wow, like look at these
fucking headshots. So like all these old,
old headshots, xannies and Nashville.
You ever do that place? I love,
all you can do is look at those pictures
every night and find something new to
the figure out. That time
I never get tired. I read,
look at them. I look at them.
Any of those clubs, I know that there's
a breed club you're talking about.
It's not a helium because they
don't haven't been open as right,
but it's those 35 year olds, 35 year
old clubs or clubs, those walls.
Holy Shit. I remember the person
I thought I look up at the wall.
Anybody that had a gimmick, I thought
they were going to be really successful.
Like one guy who was called the coach and
had a whistle and I was thinking I was
like 19 I'll be like fuck, I wish I would
have thought I was always so jealous.
Yeah, I get it. Blows the whistle and
I'm the coach got damn it. That's it.
I was always so jealous of those and
then they tend not to be doing comedy.
You know what I was really jealous of of
the dudes who had like the, the big
full page ads in that comedy guide.
Do you remember the comedy guide? I
sorta do. The comedy guide was this,
it was an industry comedy guy that
would come out like every year,
like all the managers would
have it and they would, these,
these comedians would take out these giant
full page ads and show like what Naca
Conference, you know they perform dad
and performing at colleges lot and they,
they had like this really professionally
done photography and shit.
Like that was how comedians got the
word out about it and that's
how they marketed these stuff.
To buy time in the industry guide and
then put together some VHS tape and send
it out the cards. Did you ever have
a comedy card? No, never had it.
We had a card once to promote a website
that I put out to promote my website,
but there was never one
for like, like, you know,
I'm appearing in this town like with like
pointing to the right and the big some
someone told me, what am I coming
to you? Someone told me that uh, um,
my track record is this and then I'll
tell you what somebody told me George
Carlin said, but at least I wish I
could've said I never had a card.
But I am proud to say if
I'm going to be 100% honest,
I had one for like a month and then
I just didn't like the smell of it.
So he got rid of it. I know. Yeah. I was
like, no tog glass comedian, I was like,
Oh shit. I think I saw some other
comedian with a car and I'm like,
I should have cards, you know?
And then I got rid of him.
So now I'm glad because
someone said somebody at the,
George Carlin was talking about cards
backstage at the comedy magic club and
basically said, he goes, God, you know,
and the community doesn't
have a fucking card, you know.
And then the comedian that had the card
sort of felt like he took them very
quickly over to the trash because
he had just gotten cards. Yeah.
That was a thing about
headshots back in Boston.
Anybody who's any good
had the shitty headshot,
they didn't give a fuck about
their headshots. Right, right.
And you can see that same,
that same path.
And they would talk about it like if you
hire a photographer to do your headshot,
you fucking suck on stage.
That was like,
those are just such an unspoken
are their exception. Yes. But no,
mostly that's such a great,
well there's something that makes you
want to take a picture of yourself and be
all sexy looking.
That's Uber Douchey and it
doesn't translate into comedy.
You know,
there's some guys who could ham it up.
Like I remember Kevin Knox had
like are really zany like Ted shot,
but it worked for him cause that was
like his act like he was a wild energetic
guy. What if I talk about how
bad that is and I agree with you,
but then you guys pull in line a picture
of me with my shoe is a phone. Todd,
we found this picture of you like, Oh
that with the shoe. Yeah. It was like,
it was a fun, nobody did that
then. No, I was really the first.
You know what my favorite is guys who do
characters and they have like multiple
characters on their head shots.
Like this is the hillbilly.
This is doctor.
Does anybody still do that?
No Man. I don't know.
Someone was on the podcast,
I don't know who to credit for this,
but they were talking about how um, uh,
you guys would know,
you guys remember about how the
genre of prop comedy's gone.
Carrot top room moved it.
You can't be a prop guy anymore.
But when we were starting out, that
was an option. It was like prop guys.
There was, you know, regular
standup comics. There was
dirty guys, it was prop guys.
The prop guy doesn't exist anymore.
You never see the prop guy anymore.
Carrot top essentially just
dominated the market so thoroughly that
everybody else abandoned it. Let me,
let me say this,
if somebody out there was willing,
this is a real offer to like let's say
they had money and they think it's a good
idea and then I could give them,
I will give them 40% of all my income.
If somebody goes, I will pay for it.
Todd, we build him a great property,
like we hire writers and it's the,
it's like an anti prop act.
I would go tour with it if somebody
was willing to put money into it,
like producing go, you were going
to hire, we're going to build this.
It's going to be a truck.
It's going to go and you're going to do a,
but we're going to put money into it.
Somebody out there, promoter have creator,
half promoter. Thanks. I'd fucking
do that. You would ask 40% per,
I want to put it down on record,
but we will talk about the fee.
You would actually be the perfect guy
to put together like a fake prop act,
like a prop act as that you have like,
but no disrespect,
disrespect to it.
It would be just like the opposite of it.
Like there'd be like these weird like,
I don't know,
he would just make it shitty
the way you know, like you,
if you're going to make fun of a comedian,
you tell a bunch of shitty jokes
and the punchline, now it's,
you're not disrespecting
comedy, shitty comedy. Right?
So that was what you would do. You'd be
disrespecting a shitty prop back. Yes.
And it would be just almost a mock of
a project that didn't put a lot of time
into his props. Like, no,
he's just like tape. You know?
He's like pulling things out that are
obviously, and they're not even, he goes,
it used to be taped together.
He shows the crowd.
It was a few guys that
were like combination.
They would like have a few
props and they would do comics.
Do you remember Dennis?
Melanie. Lenny Shoultz.
Do you remember crazy? Lenny?
Jesus Christ. He would,
he would pick up a fucking
smokey the bear. Okay.
He had a smokey the bear doll and he
would only, you can prevent forest fires.
Then he'd go fuck you and
punched the bear. And that
was so ridiculous. It would knock
the bear like through the crowd.
Like fuck you.
This is completely silly.
Duncan Trussell in it. Does a prop
back are used to with little Hobo.
Well it's hacky. That's a little different
though. That there's another level.
That's the other level. That's the, the,
the puppet master guy. The puppet is a,
another video camera. That kind of, Jeff
Dunham is pretty much dominated now.
I mean there's still a few
other guys. Like there's the,
uh, the guy a faith tour.
What's his name? Fader. Terry
Fator. Terry Fator. Oh yeah,
a big one in Vegas as well.
Um, and, but that's, you know,
there's not like many young guns out
there with a fucking taking a doll to a
coffee club
and he's got a lot of guys
that are rocking that Ad.
I think so. You know the visual
of the hand just instantly.
I just picture the comedy club. I was
just out a week ago. What are the odds?
Like I would walk up on stage seriously
and you put your hand up and made the
fake puppets. Well, the best of all time,
best of all time in my opinion is auto
and George the best of all time I worked
with Datto. We did a gang of gigs in a
danger fields in New York. We did prom
shows, which are helacious. Have you ever
done the prom show? Oh I've, I've done a,
yeah,
one or two when they have them in New
York City where they just keep funneling
the people into the club.
They get these kids from high schools
and they bring them in and they,
they don't end the show.
They tell you to do new material
every time and they, they are,
they tell you not to do new material,
that to tell you the same material every
time so that they would realize that
the show was over because they
never cleaned the place out.
They just kept packing kids in there,
uh,
violating every fire code
in existence and would,
and it would go on til five
o'clock in the morning. I mean,
you would start working at eight at
night and you would do shows until five
o'clock in the morning.
They would just keep rotating the lineup.
I would leave and it would be light out.
It was madness.
But for like a young comic,
it's a pretty good cause it's like 75
bucks a sat or something like that and
you're packing all those sets
together. So it was, it was, uh,
a good chunk of money for,
for Canadians.
So a lot of us did it and odd when I did
band and we did a I a couple of clubs,
I'd never got to work with him that much.
I only get to see him like three times
live. I remember just punching, you know,
it's nice when you go to see someone
like that and the people around you are
enjoying as much as you do, like a ton
of people in really fucking enjoy him.
And then I feel like there's like
people like me that go, it's fucking,
I can't handle it. I want to be around
those people and I wouldn't wear,
the last time I saw him, the couple
next to me, husband and wife,
I found that they were w I,
we just started punching each other and
we're glad we had someone, the punch,
you know, and the people ahead of
us. We're sort of the same way.
Everyone else was loving it, but we
were definitely going, I'm going to die.
You know, it was just so, it is what it
comedy festival. And he was saying health,
desperate, older comedians. And
then he went, I give to understand.
I felt like I never saw them my
whole life when he, when he goes, um,
like something happens.
And then de jure,
I get it mixed up right now I'm talking
about, oh, and George auto would say, uh,
he'd say as a woman in the crowd,
like, hey, how are you? And He,
the puppet would mock him.
It's crowd work was holy Shit.
Are you shitting me?
That's what you find in a Lillian. He
has stopped to chauffeur. Hey, hello. Oh,
he goes up. Then it would like to see
a puppet really dig into a human being.
I had never seen that,
and for me that was fucking unbelievable.
He used to have a fucking
thing he was working on.
It was Kennedy getting shot in the head
and saw the puppet's head would flip
back like a flop up of scalp,
which he goes and I want to figure
out how to put a brain in there.
Maybe square blood out of it.
That's hilarious.
He was so funny and people will get mad.
They would go, I see your lips moving.
He didn't try to hide that.
His lips are moving like,
what is he not understanding what
he's doing? I see. Guess what?
That has to be certifiably. No, no, no,
no bullshit. A problem with the mental,
the mental disability. It's a fucking
puppet. Of course, his lips are moving.
Just pay attention to what he's doing,
but that's someone there that was taking
it for face value. Oh Wow. How was he?
Well, I didn't hard to get past the
blips. You know, I saw his lips moving.
So George,
obviously he's still doing club dates.
Yeah, he's a maniac, but
he's just so crazy. I know.
So He's, he's fucking hilarious. What
was that picture of me? You're in a prop.
What was it? You and a
bag. Oh, did somebody make,
did I used to do props? No, I
don't think I did that ever.
I do that or did they Photoshop? It looks
like it was like a red carpet event.
You from the American beauty or
something like that. Oh, Jesus.
I wonder if,
I wonder if there's hope for,
for the, uh, what, what would they
call him? Puppet acts. What's the,
somebody will have to do it. Great.
Ventriloquist. Yeah. The wonder. Yeah.
I mean it feels, I feel like that's a
genre that can be fucked with, you know,
Dunkin did it, but he only did it for
like this one bit, which is hilarious.
Beautiful.
A Little Hobo.
Little Hobos is evil puppet and killed
his grandfather and he does this one bit.
It's fucking genius, but it's not a lot
of like young guys. And he'd go to a club.
It's very rare that you see
a young guy that's a puppet
act. Yeah. Yeah. You don't,
is there anything else? We're not
thinking of a willy, Tyler and Lester.
He was another famous ones. Yeah. No,
I mean that you don't think of another
type of comedy. Yeah. Oh, oh. Any style.
When I think of someone doing it,
I think if somebody has may be mocking it.
That's what, but what about not mocking
it? Could somebody come back and make it?
It was just that good and they,
right.
Why can't it be good banter
between the puppet and the person?
Certainly the book it is with Auto,
right? That's what I'm saying. But we're,
we're excluding him guys.
He's got some jokes where he goes back
and forth with the puppets that are
pretty fucking funny. We'll know then.
Then that to me is always amazing.
But I know that the, the
cliche stuff, it's like,
I think Jeff Dunham does it like
more of like family friendly.
Like he tries intentionally to sort
of, uh, is there a good psychic,
does that exist? Well, I
mean like comedian psychics,
I've never even heard of one.
I've heard of a comedy hypnotists.
Juva juvenile never. Oh, you have an
opinion on that. They'll way it works.
It definitely works. Yeah. Comedy
hypnotism is 100% real. Okay.
Here's why I'm sort of, not that you're
the all knowing, but you know, I usually,
you probably broke it down
without even getting into detail.
You probably shred it the fuck out of it.
And so I think you probably
know the right answer.
So I'm glad because here's what my problem
with is. If it was fake and I thought,
no, I can't explain it, but here's what I
used to say. I can't explain it. I don't.
But here's the one thing.
If it's fake,
how come never do those
audience members on stage break?
Never. Never. Now. So are they in
some hip? What's happening here?
You can tell they can tell a good
guy whether someone's under not.
And some people you just can't hypnotize.
I think there's really some people that
have brains that are easier to hack.
I agree.
I think you could just get into him.
I'll tell you this for a fact because
I worked with a named Frank Santos,
the r rated hypnotist. I worked
with him many, many, many, many,
many times.
Back in the Boston days when I was an
open miker and I was 100% skeptical,
the first time I saw it I was like,
this is bullshit. These people,
I'll just faking it,
but then when you watch a guy actually
come in his pants and you watch people do
things that he's telling them to do,
then you realize, oh, wait a minute.
I'm a control freak. It would never
work on me, but it works on some people.
Some people, especially
in the, in that context,
it actually might work better because
they're nervous and they get on stage and
there's a bright light and this guy just
knows how to lock you in and tell you
what to do, tell you what to
do. You're going to breathe,
you're going to breathe in on the
count of five, you're going to just go,
you're going to go to sleep, relax all
the muscles in your body. One, two, three,
four,
five.
And he would touch these guys and they
would fucking collaterally for me.
I could just feel that. I swear to
God. No, I mean it just let it in.
Three seconds just to go. Someone is
counting down and let your shoulders down.
But he was a real hypnotist first and
then he got into comedy hypnotist.
Let me ask you this, and someone that
knows a lot about this might even say,
well no Todd, that's not hypnotism, but
what? Even if it's this, because look,
they get laughs and the
average person to get laughs,
it's how's it feel to get laughs?
It feels unfucking believable.
So let's say even if a Naysayer said, I,
ed tries to answer the question this way,
I still might not negate to hypnotism,
but what if a Naysayer said,
now they're just getting lamps.
And when people get those type of lifts,
they get comfortable.
So they get,
they let their guard them because
everything they do is getting a laugh.
They're getting a laugh cause
there's a professional up.
They're making it happen.
So maybe they get more
comfortable and more comfortable.
So the more weirdness is thrown at them,
they're getting the laugh. It feels good.
And they go to the,
you're still take him somewhere.
So if you're doing it
through laughter there,
you're taking them somewhere to do some
shit that they're not doing in their
normal lives. Yeah, I don't, I
don't know what the conscious,
like the interpretation of the person
who's actually doing it to some of them
see what they're doing to other ones.
See something that's not even there.
I don't, I don't understand that
because one of them he did, he said, uh,
he was, he had a weird way of talking
about a very strange accent and he'd say,
you about to make love to Madonna.
Madonna is on the ground. She's naked.
You're on top of a,
you're going to make love to Madonna.
And this guy starts fucking,
I mean, he starts fucking,
and the crowds is,
is it stitches?
Stitches Comedy Club in Boston. This
is the stitches to the second stitches.
There's one that was
attached to the paradise.
It was this old school place that's the
first place that ever performed an open
mic night at that place went under and
then they opened up a new place and this
was at the new place. He,
the guy came in his pants.
I saw the guy come in his pants like,
I mean, I ain't go go look at them.
But I mean it was pretty obvious that
the guy came in his pants and he was
embarrassed and everyone was laughing and
he didn't know what the fuck they were
laughing at.
He was gone.
He was in a weird other place and
when he snapped him out of it,
you could tell the guy is, I don't
think they're that good of an actor.
I think that you are skeptical because
it wouldn't work on you at all and I
don't think it would work on me there.
But think about some of the shit
that people are willing to do.
Think about cults.
Think about people joining cults that
they think about people that believe that
some,
some guy who lives in Siberia is Jesus.
And so they're going to set up these
huts and live up there with Jesus because
Jesus is back and he lives in Siberia.
Do you have to be like,
there's something has to be like really
wrong with your brain for you to accept
that?
I think people's brains are jiff and
just like people's dicks are different.
That's what I think.
And I think some people you can just tell
them what to do and they'll just lock
into it and just do it. Yeah.
I mean, cause if you, we,
we know that like the first part of what
you said is true because it's happened
in the past. People following cold. So
like, so what if that light, light, light,
light, light is someone just doing
that for an hour? Like they'll do that.
Why won't you just go, you know, like
there's yeah, right. People. Yeah.
There's a lot of your Ryka
I always, um, I always, uh,
forget that. I'm like, really? But
then you think, yeah, that's you.
I'm thinking of me picking at me.
Yeah,
you can't think of you because you
have an extraordinary job. It's very,
you have a very unusual amount of people
that you come in contact with and share
your ideas with and you're on stage
all the time. This is like your,
your comfort level with
humans is different than
the average person's comfort
level cause he experienced humans
and it's really extreme state,
the state of a standup comedy club.
So it's real hard to,
to just couldn't hypnotize a guy like you.
But there's some people out there that
have nine volt brains and you know,
everybody else has a, a bunch of those
lithium ions. They used to run a Tesla,
not this motherfucker.
He's got a nine volt brain just like God
gives some men two inch painting says
this guy has a nine volt brain
and that is what he's got.
You know,
and I say this from a person who's very
acutely aware of how smart I am or how
lack of smart I am.
You put a math problem in front of me,
I start fucking drooling. I'm an idiot.
I'm really bad when it comes to math.
Like I'm shockingly bad.
You know,
there's just shit I'm not
good at even slightly. But
I know that it's, I'm not confused.
You know what I mean? Could it,
cause you're able to know where you're,
you're right. I get what you're saying.
So I know there's different levels.
I know there's people that are way
smarter than me. I just know it. I've a,
because mathematically I feel like I,
I'm, I'm horrible at math too. Right?
I know I didn't choose that.
That so you're saying there might be
people that get the math thing but then
socially or like given these
nine volt batteries and that's,
you think it's not changeable? I think
it is. I think if I had interest in,
in mathematics, but what I'm saying
is I don't, and because I don't,
I don't have any knowledge of it,
so I'm really dumb when
it comes to that subject.
It's not something I've ever pursued.
So because of that,
I completely lack any comprehension
of like really advanced calculus.
And you only see like those physics guys,
I have zero knowledge of what that is.
It's because when I was a kid,
I associated it very early with something
incredibly boring and because I did
that, I just never put any effort into
it whatsoever. It wasn't rewarding to me.
I think that's what, yeah, I
think that's what makes things,
it's you should have a comprehensive
knowledge of how to count and divide and
all those things.
The absolutely,
but it doesn't appeal to everybody and
to make a guy like you or make a guy like
me chase after like really complex math,
it's not really beneficial because it's
not going to do anything more than let
us know that we don't really like math,
especially in this day and age because
there's not a matter of there's a finite
amount of time to learn things
when you're in high school,
finite amount of time in college
and finite amount of the time.
When you have a job,
he's so fucking small amount,
so cut out all the shit you're
not really that interested in.
There's plenty of fucking
calculators out there.
Stop trying to be mister renaissance man.
When it comes to knowledge,
there's a calculator punching those
numbers, get it done. It's really easy.
Even help board don't or be a math guy.
I'm so bad at math. Now granted this
look sad or this looks Saturday.
This is going to tell Saturday than it is,
but it is a true story.
So it all has to do with math and how
bad I am and I have to tell you that I
like bubble tape.
There's a reason I have to tell
you that because I don't know why,
but I'll buy bubble tape. You
know pop, pop, pop stuff comes in.
It's like baseball tape
and you pull a piece out.
You can make it like 10 feet long. You
know it's all in. It's all like in a,
it's like,
I know what I'm talking about.
It's like one big long piece of gum
and then you pull it out. It's gum,
you chew gum bubble, bubble
tape go. Oh. Oh, okay.
It's hard to, most people listening are
probably, they'll, they'll know. I'm like,
that's my,
that's like meet a nice way of me going.
Everyone knows with you I think, but
I could be wrong. I bet you're right.
I'm an idiot. Um, so, uh, so anyway,
so I'm on the plane and I'm horrible
with numbers and I have like I'm at this,
I have a checkbook and I'm
opening it up, you know, cause I,
and I'm counting with my fingers
and I'm figuring something out.
And also then I take a piece of bubble
tape and I eat it at the same time.
And then I, there's a guy in my brief
and I look at him like, oh my God,
I thought instantly what he had just seen
like not a man my age county with his
fingers, you know, pull it Eaton bubble
tape. There's no way you think there's,
I have any amount of success. He has to
think, oh that poor guy, good for him.
Get on a plane and oh, am I one of the
look up? No, no, I swear everything.
All right. It looks very archaic
but I don't like I'm aware.
So it's funny that that's eccentric.
Like to eat childish sort of candy that
we have like in categorized like this is
candy for children. Well, it's true.
It's like if God forbid and I don't,
so don't worry about judging me. Those
big lollipops you can get. Oh yeah.
What if you really liked go as a full
grown adult eating one of those big
lollipop?
I think you should be able to do whatever
the fuck you want knickers on you.
I think it's so stupid.
Can I tell you I wish you like those and
I'll tell you why. Because if you did,
I hang out with you every night and
just see if anyone gave you shit.
I would love to see it. What's up
man? You know I like these lollipops.
You would address it. The
lollipop industry would love
you because he'd be like,
it's Nice Joe Rogan's out there,
but they give him shit about eating.
The big lolly puppy tells him to go
fuck himself handedly bringing back the
fanny pack, Todd glass or you can
go handedly. I wear it everywhere.
I wear it every time I go on the road.
People point to it.
And you'll get the fuck out of here.
And I go, yeah, I'm wearing a fat.
It's fucking easy. It's easy
to travel with. You know?
I don't know if I'll ever wear one,
but I've said this a million times.
Why can't the fanny pack be cool to
where it is? I don't. I have shit.
Mike flew long nights just with
where to put pot. That lollipop.
Exactly the one I was thinking I
would eat one of those where you
talk last car confused. Look
at that fucking lollipop.
That's a lot of sugar sign.
How much sugar is that Todd glass.
That's a fucking hard piece
of sugar that weighs pounds.
I don't think it probably puts
you in a straight diabetic coma.
A girl should not eat that and not
be looking for and it guy or girl.
If you're out licking that lollipop
nonstop that Amar and I don't think if
people,
you're going to attract some Weirdos board
or some people who really admire your
tongue. Exactly. Yeah. Maybe you
have a really sweet tongue. I mean,
you know,
some girls stick their tongues out and
they go all the way down their chin and
he, yeah. [inaudible] your
friends would say, dad,
you're looking at that lollipop
and public. It's, you're,
you're only going to attract
the wrong type of guy.
You can't attract the right
type of guys. Fuck, hey,
let's get it as Josie has, would say,
let's get this party started, Brian. Okay.
Alright, listen, stop it. Brian.
Stop it. You confusing everything.
Um, yeah. Well I think like lollipops,
like anything else, man, look,
whatever the fuck you like this.
We aren't here for a long time.
If you like something, they just say
you like it and say why you like it.
And when, when I, when I say it was
bringing back the fanny pack, you know,
people thought it was joking. Like
I've really never stopped wearing one.
When I travel I'd wear of the people
would constantly mocked me. I'm like,
I don't care. It's a fucking, it's,
I think it's insane that I can wear
a backpack and no one gives a shit,
but everywhere pack down here, all of
a sudden it's something that's funny.
I'm like, that's gears. Nothing.
And here's the thing. You're right.
But here's the problem.
Here's the problem.
Like I know you're right and not only do
I know you're right, but the here comes,
there's the end part. Um, I've said
it over the last year so many times,
especially if if, uh, if you
have a pipe or a key I playing,
I don't like to have my phone on me.
I thought she got damn it.
Why can't fanny packs like I just said be,
why can't they be cool to
where we're bringing him back?
Todd glass? I don't know.
If I have, I'd be too insecure. I be
too insecure. Just everywhere I went.
People would be like, look,
that guy wearing a fanny pack.
He would feel like you
were being courageous,
but it makes courageous
and just carrying stuff.
Wear sweatpants. Fuck it. Sweatpants
and a fanny pack. Fuck him.
Who am I dressing up for some
nice soft cotton sweatpants.
Those are like the most comfortable things
ever, you know? But we never wear him.
No. Let me get my and stiff
ass stupid plastic pants on.
You know what I was, uh,
last night in Santa Barbara,
it was Halloween and there were some
people walking around in costumes. I go,
forget about the costume and what it is.
Just what they're able to wear.
Like a onesy right.
Walking around with, with,
with the comfortable slippers
and they're comfortable.
Like why can't they do that every
night? Maybe minus the, the,
the costume part of it.
But like every,
I thought how many people are getting
to walk the streets in a freedom?
It's like walking. It's like
swimming naked in a, in a
bathtub, in a pool. Probably.
They're just walking around like with
all that, just comfortable shit. Right?
Like right. Cause you were saying, why
can't we just walk around and, yeah.
Like why, oh, in a fanny pack. Yeah, but
what would the type of pants you said? Oh,
sweatpants. Yeah, like nothing's
more comfortable in sweatpants.
So thing at one point were
giving up anything. We,
we've developed the most
comfortable pair of pants there is,
but we choose to go
well but that's so many.
Gave me a pair of these slippers that
are like kind of like borderline between
slippers and a shoe.
It's real close.
I think they'll like uggs from
man or something like that.
The inside is all like golf fleecy
it's comfortable, so comfortable.
And so a friend of mine came over and uh,
I put them on and I go,
hey man, what's up? And he goes, what are
you wearing? Fucking slippers is there,
are they the crocs, the ones with the
no, no, they weren't crocs. They're,
they're like,
they're like leather on the outside but
they have like a lining and the lining
is like, like fleece, like like lamb
scan or whatever the hell did they have.
There was like, what does that slipper, I
was like, it's fucking shoe or something.
But to him it was like, it was like
he wears slippers bro. You're like,
why are you wearing, what are you trying
to have fucking your feet be all soft.
Weird is against
something that feels good.
Why you wearing slippers?
He doesn't realize it. That's the thing
he doesn't realize, but breaking it down.
That's what he's saying.
You're wearing something that's more
comfortable than everybody else.
You're wearing slippers
anywhere in a fanny pack.
I might even say the same thing,
but at least I'm willing to.
I'm not from that one. If I see someone
wearing slippers, you know what?
I'm gonna do goat. It's a great
idea. It's a fucking wonderful idea.
How about rod and I mean, I
mean he, that's why, I mean I,
I want to live to be the age where I
can show up at the Improv in probably my
pajamas. I took that for granted
when I used to see him doing that.
He would then you sort of
wear pajamas and slippers.
He would wait bathrobe on stage with
nothing underneath it. I was working,
this is when I was working. I wasn't,
I, I saw him. I was getting paid.
I didn't know what the marketing arena,
I was working at great woods center for
the performing arts when I was 19 and
Rodney was there backstage. He didn't
give a fuck. He had no underwear on,
no clothes on, who were fucking
bathrobe and everybody's like,
it's caucus just fucking hanging out.
He doesn't give a shit. Rodney's, Hey,
what are you saying? What do you
say back there? Just getting fired
up on weed and he would go onstage in
his bathrobe and he fucking destroyed.
There's the human, his bathrobe.
That's how he would dress backstage.
Paul's Bullshit. He didn't give a
fuck. He didn't give a fuck man.
He didn't want to wear anything but a
bathrobe and so he would go on stage like
that and he would feel so funny because
he was fucking naked up there and it was
half of the fun half the fun of the show.
I never knew the bathrobe thing
all it goes us the pajamas,
but that's just beautiful. I'll
never forget man. I was about,
I guess I was probably 19 years old
and I was in this back area where the
performance go right before they go
onstage and I got a glimpse of Rodney like
pacing before he went on in
his bathrobe and I wasn't even,
I had no comedic aspirations
back then whatsoever, like zero,
but I always loved stand up comedy and
so I remember looking in there and go to
holy shit,
that's fucking Rodney Dangerfield right
there and he's in a bathrobe and then we,
they would all tell me like
the guys who were backstage,
the security was doing back
there, they were like, dude,
his balls are hanging out and just
party and he gives zero fucks.
He's like 70 or something. I don't
know how he old, he was back then,
but he had to be in his sixties like
deep in the 60s he was still doing blow.
He didn't give a fuck. He was a maniac.
You know the way, the way, it's awesome.
The way to explain what it was like,
explain what it was like to meet Rodney.
I was trying to explain this. I think over
the years. I think once when I was, uh,
somebody in my family or something, I was
like, it was very hard. But I think I,
I can do a better job of it now,
but like,
you know how we'll never
get to meet homer Simpson?
He's a character and you're not going
to get to meet Peter from the family.
You know, you don't get to meet them.
You get to meet Rodney. Like you don't,
you're not supposed to get to meet him.
He's so larger than life that it's hard.
Yeah.
I have seen other people that are on TV
when I was younger and when I saw them
in public, yes. I was like,
Oh yeah, there's that person.
But Rodney was different.
It was like, what the fuck that, that's
real. Because he was such, you know,
like a cartoon character, you know
what I mean? In a good way. He was a,
in the movies too, and he was like
larger than life was disrespectful,
but he was, he was, he was, he was,
he was, it was, it was amazing.
And then,
and then he knew and they capitalized
on it later with the suit and a red tie.
And there you see this. Oh
my God. So anything he said,
I went once to see Bob Nelson
opened up for him and he,
it's not a great story,
but it's all I've got.
So any little piece that I happen to have
anything, I'm with Rodney, I'm happy,
you know? So I remember seeing him
and being like, that was just weird.
And then a Bob goes, hey, this
is Todd. He's from Philly.
And he goes, that's good.
Philadelphia needs him.
We laughed so hard,
laugh so hard because it was funny.
But later when he left, I went,
what did that mean? I don't know. No one
knew. It didn't matter what it meant.
It was Rodney. And, and it's
not like we were fake laughing.
It was just him fucking be.
And that funding to go, they
pulled off. He needs him.
It was funny.
I got a chance to see him alive then.
And then several years later at the
laugh, stop, uh, uh, laugh factory rather.
I got to see him at the laugh factory on
sunset a couple times there. Like when,
like what year?
I would say it was the 90s
and how it wasn't 90 days.
Did he go up and do it pretty
tight set hazing. He was killer.
Who's killed even back then. I mean
he, he didn't go onstage and half acid,
that's for sure. He was crushing. He
was really fun and he was just chilling,
hanging out. His wife was with him,
attractive woman who was like, you know,
30 40 years younger than him.
It'd be just looked like he was
having a great fucking time.
He rode that thing right
into the fucking rocks.
He took that boat and just whoa
and wrote it right into the rocks.
And he's 70 years old and he's
crushing onstage, partying,
hanging out with a hot senorita. Jesus
Christ. He was an animal. That's,
that's, that's so much.
I, you know, that's,
when you look at it from that perspective,
it's like,
just amplifies what you're already know
was like, yeah, fucking, he really did.
He really do day or you know,
I'm sure a lot of it's true,
but the thing that most people know
is like by the time he could enjoy it,
he felt it was too late, but he still
had a lot of fun. Right? Yeah. Oh,
he had a great fucking time.
Yeah, he was Rodney Dangerfield.
He might as nice to people too.
That was the other thing about Rodney.
He helped comics out.
His Hbo specials were legendary.
Like a lot of people don't really even
know like what a huge stand up he was.
He was a huge comedian, like great woods
where I worked, where he performed,
I mean I don't know how many thousands
of people it is and it has to be at least
like seven or 8,000 people in the,
in the part that's covered.
And then there's like this back like
hill area that's like the grass,
which is all like open wandering around.
It was really crazy.
Like what their idea was ridiculous
because the idea was you would take these
people and you and some of them would
be seated in his beautiful amphitheater
and then pass them.
You would just stuff the grass,
which is enormous patch of grass with
savages who couldn't hear anybody who was
talking on stage.
So it was really unfortunate because like
he needs what you saw him? Yeah, yeah.
I got to see him close though.
I heard it.
But then I went to the grass
because people were complaining.
They were coming down.
They'd say, hey, we can't,
we can't understand a fucking word. He's
saying we've got tickets to the grass.
And so I went out to the grass and I was
like, oh no, you couldn't hear anything.
It was this weird echoey thing. So when
it would come out of the amphitheater,
you had no idea what he's talking about.
You'd hear people laugh and you'd go,
Oh fuck, this is terrible. So will
they like ripped all these people off?
And so they, you know, the, unfortunately
it didn't get a chance to see him,
but he was in his prime and he was,
this was, he was a really fucking,
really funny guy. But his big
thing was helping other Comedians,
those Hbo Comedy Festivals Launched
Kennison launched dice clay launched bill
Hicks and, and you know what? I'm
going to give him a huge compliment.
And it's not like I'm complimenting
myself cause I don't know if I, Hey,
we only can live to,
if I got to that point,
if I did what Rodney didn't,
but up to now I haven't.
So I'm not doing it from
a place of judgment.
So it's nobody's job to come
and help other comedians. So we,
I'm not saying it from that point
of view. No, no, no, no, no.
I'm saying it's just sometimes you get
someone that loves comedy so much that on
their own they go,
you know what,
there's some people I know are
fucking funny that, you know,
back then it wasn't even TV.
There wasn't a lot of avenues.
So it was Rodney specials.
They weren't getting on the tonight show.
Some were did both, but a lot
were like his vehicle. So no one,
since Rodney has ever done that. No. No
one. And if I'm wrong, I want to know.
I don't want to be,
you know,
I'm not saying like if somebody looks
something up and goes, this comedian did,
I'd be like, well, they're cool too.
Martin Lawrence didn't, he
didn't? No, no, no, no, no.
Robert Townsend did a few of those.
He did a few of those.
Then you do a few of those where he
brought up different comics like Damon
Wayans. I remember did one
then, then so, so I like that.
That's a guy that kind of disappeared.
Robert Townsend. You remember that guy?
Yeah. Whatever happened to that guy. Yeah,
that's a good question. He just sort of,
I don't know what happened that day. He
was really respected. It was hilarious.
He was really funny. Did he do, what did
he do? Um, it wasn't a Hollywood shuffle,
was it?
I don't know.
I'm not good with movies.
Yeah. I'm not eating them at
home. Yeah. Robert Townsend.
Oh my God. Yeah. He was hilarious, man.
Whatever happened.
I remember that special where he came
at w what was the special where he came
out and he was talking in
the accent and then he, oh,
he broke character after like a minute.
I don't remember.
That was on one of Rodney's maybe was it?
Yeah,
but anyway,
I hope that came out right.
That's just very admirable that Rodney
did that and you know what made it even
more admirable because he was so big.
It's not like he needed it.
Certain comedians may have done it when
they're at a point in their career when
it needs them or they need it.
Rodney didn't need that. He,
I think he used his power to get a
special and do something you wanted to do.
I don't think he needed that.
Like Rodney, they called you.
They want you to host this. It was
something he perpetuated the, he had sorta
past.
That's why it was sorta cool.
This is Robert towns right here is this
Hollywood shuffle. Meteor man. Meteor man.
He did a lot of really funny movies,
man. And he was a funny comic too. Yeah.
Yeah. What's he doing now? I
don't know where is it? Maybe
just said, you know what,
I'm good.
He's only 56 you knew also dresses like
pretty much how they want on stage and
almost every day is don Barris.
He'll,
he'll just wear like boxers and
my jetpack. Yeah, well that's,
that's the thing, you know, be
uncomfortable. What do you wear on stage?
Whatever I'm wearing, I'd like to wear
something that's not too distracting.
I like to wear something
that's a comfortable just,
I usually like to wear like I work,
converse all stars pretty much every day.
Once I started wearing those, I realize
like if I wear a regular shoe now,
like anything that has a heel,
like a running shoe,
it feels weird to be like
in that different posture.
You're not supposed to stand like that.
I suppose stand flat and outside were
like them because they're flat and
comfortable. You feel as you're tilting
forward you are. We just, I'm so,
it's so rare for me. The only time I
wear shoe shoes is want to do the UFC.
Do you think?
Do you think like even I know exactly
what you're talking about because I've put
the,
I get used to it after a while,
but there's a pair of boots and after
I'm not wearing them for a while ago.
What am I, what's the go forward here? So
we're women do that. Do you think that,
yes, I'm going to take from that to this,
but I'm curious of your opinion on this.
Do you think like for women wearing high
heels it might hurt them more than they
may be think cause it's a
horrible thing to do to yourself?
I think it's probably, and it is
really difficult to do every day.
I think women who wear them
everyday just to, to uh, their job.
I like to wear high heels around the
office constantly and that's all you were
at work. Ooh, I got to think that's
brutal and punishing on your feet.
I got to think that. Yeah. I don't see
how it couldn't be. Could you be doing,
let me ask you this.
Some people will go,
could you be doing it just for yourself
instead of putting it from, you know,
so he could, I know I don't. You could be.
Yeah, they could do it for other girls.
There's,
well,
there's a misperception about women that
everything they do is to attract men
and as that's certainly has some
merit to it, but it's not everything.
They also do it to show up
other girls like girls and,
and to be like impressive to other girls.
Oh that's that Chinese thing,
that foot binding thing that they
do. Whoa. Where they smashed.
They smashed their feet down.
They want their feet to be small.
People are so crazy.
The size of the feet means so much to
them buying their feet up into this crazy
positions. Oh, that's so crazy
at all the things that people do.
That is one of the weirdest ones.
All the body modification things
that people do culturally,
like really common body modifications.
The foot binding one is so bizarre.
Like really, really fucking weird. Yeah.
That's not just respecting other cultures.
That's, come on, that's a port.
There's a problem. It's torture.
There's something sane about it.
Women in Africa that are, uh,
the Suaree women who are the,
I think it's Surrey where they make that,
that big plate in their face.
The young ones are rejecting it now
they're going, fuck that. This is crazy.
Like I'm not wearing a fucking plate in
my lip anymore. And like they're like,
they're getting sorta like,
uh,
there's a cultural rift with the young
ones don't want to knock their teeth out
and where this plate you have to knock
your lower teeth out to where those
plates, it's fucking cool. You know,
their knowledge cause the,
cause we're in a computer age where
they're give there. Yeah, that's,
they're not even getting,
I don't even think they're getting that
much impact from the computer world and
these like really remote tribes.
I'm not sure I probably be wrong.
I'm probably wrong.
It's probably someone with a laptop and
a fucking cellular connection that gets
online or something when I got
to feel like you're wearing it,
you and me really super
tribal environment.
They've topless wearing skins and stuff.
Like some of them it's like really crazy.
Like,
how similar that the way they are living
today as the way they were living like
hundreds of thousands of years ago.
What were we talking about? Right.
But like just uh, leading up to this but
the same thing. Um, body modifications.
Foot binding. Oh yeah,
the foot binding. Yeah.
What I was thinking there's got
to be one of your listeners could,
could look this up for
you guys or you could,
there's gotta be someone that's
living today that did that,
but move past it in this world.
There's got to be one that tells a story.
Do your foot. I think once your
foot's bound up your fox or did it,
but then you're right.
I'm sorry,
did it and then tells the story like move
past it mentally is a point going and
that was what am I doing
and how do you know people,
I don't know how you would do that though.
Like can it be somebody is
stuck like that forever? No,
no one do your thought like explain
the thought process. Well it's,
I think it's just cultural
conditioning. You know, there's,
we have a we really weird problem as
human beings that once a group of us start
doing a thing, even if that
thing is ultimately detrimental,
once a group of us start doing it,
people want to join in, it seems normal.
We can rationalize because other ones
are doing it. It's, it makes sense.
That's how the lip thing gets started.
They put this giant plate in your
lip and the bigger the plate,
the more cattle you're worth. What
does that noise, do you hear that?
You know what I thought it was,
I thought you were bringing in like a
sound effects. Yeah. It sounds like,
is it an airplane? Yeah.
Crash space shuttle.
I'm sure. What, okay.
Whatever. What was my point?
I was doing my ventriloquism. That's
pretty good. Look what was my point?
What was it like? Oh, we were talking
about, um, um, oh, the, the modification,
the foot binding saying all that stuff
was really bizarre. Yeah. The, the uh,
the foot binding, the lip
thing, you know, it's,
it's really bizarre that there's these
cultures out there that are really still
like super, super primitive.
You know, to this day,
apparently a lot of them were like
really fucking happy and healthy though.
That's the weird thing about these
indigenous people. When you find them,
you don't find a lot of like problems
that a lot of people in the city have like
psychological problems.
It's very rare.
It's very rare that people have like
psychological issues while they're the
winners. Right? I mean, seriously.
Oh, if they're happy, I guess so,
but I don't think it's impossible to
be happy in this world. I, you know,
I think that there's a lot of
people that don't get there,
but I think it's possible.
I think it's possible for anybody
to be happy in this world.
I think did this world though is insanely
complex and it requires a much more
rigid idea of what you're going to accept
and not accept in your life and what
what you're going to put out there and
what you're going to try to get back now.
I think that that's, it's
very, very, very complex.
This is an insanely intricate in woven
society and these cultural tribes.
That's really what we're designed for.
We're designed for these, you know,
these environments,
these places where as you know,
500 of us that live in a village together.
That's,
that's what we're designed
for psychologically.
That's what our brains are designed for.
When we,
you jack it up to 7 billion
people in contact with each other,
it's going to require some adjustments
and that's what we're going through right
now.
It's not that they're,
it's going to be impossible for people
to be happy in this crazy day and age.
It's just a little bit
more to manage and it a,
it brings you to this
movie that I just watched.
I was on a plane coming back from England
and I watched a summertime in Paris.
I think it's, that's what it is.
Is that Woody Allen's moving?
Was it summertime in Paris? Let me see
if it's, it's the Owen Wilson movie.
Well, that's what I was, what was
really funny. He was doing woody Allen
movie. Woody Allen movie. Come on.
What's the movie? Springtime. Paris,
forget your trouble.
Who's,
come on when you Google woody Allen in
midnight in Paris. That's what it is.
Midnight in Paris. Sorry.
Not Summertime and, uh, it,
it was hilarious in this weird, it was,
well, it was a good movie first of all,
but it was, what's it
about? It's about a guy, um,
it's basically a woody Allen movie.
He's woody Allen.
Owen Wilson's doing woody Allen like eve,
his mannerisms,
but he's not admitting it. No, no, no.
He's not admitting it at all. He's like,
is this a trailer for it?
Is that one of those things that nobody
will watch how he does it? Like what?
Yeah,
he's so measured and even
it's very woody Allen. Like,
that's great.
We can spend some time together,
a lot of commitments, but
I'm sure it's, well, what,
yeah. Did you have your slippers on when
you watch this? Oh, snake, that's worth,
because I was blessed by his wife.
He was never married to Ron Antisocial,
quite as taken with him as you are.
It's a pseudo in electrical,
slightly more tannic than the 59.
Okay.
I don't remember what thinking
you're right. And then I go,
don't just say he's right to say he's
right. Like Todd really pay attention.
But that's, once you look
for it, then you just see it.
Every single joke he's doing what he, and
he does it brilliantly. It's brilliant.
He's really amazing. And this movie
is that perfect? What would, would,
would his contemporaries think he should
just sort of give an homage to it or do
you have to mention it? I don't know
if you do, but that's what he's doing.
I think what he wrote it for,
it means to playing a character.
Obviously he's not playing
Owen Wilson. What do, yeah,
what do you need to read it?
Oh, he did woody Allen Film. He
didn't know it was woody Allen did.
And yes, it's a woody Allen film. So
let me see if, what if I ran out crying?
I don't want to get a writer
and director Woody Allen.
It's so obviously woody Allen
movie that basically, Oh,
and him agreed that he
would do it as woody Allen.
So it's like he can't do those movies
anymore, but he's got them in his head,
you know, so what it but what he
can really star and movies anymore.
People don't want to see him anymore.
That whole thing with his daughter,
and this is just,
it got so weird with so many people that
regardless of whether they're happy or
not, it's so tie boot taboo that
they've sort of ostracized him.
They allow him to be behind the scenes,
but if he's in front of the camera,
like people are really sketchy about it.
Unfortunately or fortunately,
what could this work for him and
yes, we'll do it. You get on Wilson,
do every fucking movie and do it as Woody
Allen and woody on and can crank out a
million fucking hits. It would
be amazing. I'm telling you,
this movie did not get
nearly as much credit,
like it only got a 7.7 on the IMD be,
I dunno if that's good or bad,
but I thought it was a, it was a woody
Allen movie and if you take again,
some people are not willing to take away
their feelings of him as an individual
shields work. I don't know. I,
I know there was some madness with
him and his wife and the, you know,
the Wyatt mentioned his wife.
She, uh, well, you know,
that woman makes it look like,
what was her name? Woody Allen.
Then Mia Farrow, Mia
Farrow, and uh, he looked,
man threw a cup of
fucking Hollywood people.
Who knows what the fuck the truth really
is. There are a bunch of nutty people,
but ultimately he wound up leaving
with her adopted daughter. Yes,
I know about that dance. You
know? That's crazy, man. I mean,
he was with her from the time
when she was like to, you know,
don't try to be funny. You have an opinion
about that. That's, that's fucked up.
Yeah. I mean, I think they adopted
her when she was a baby. She was,
wasn't his biological daughter. So, you
know, it's true. Obviously judgment,
all the judgments, all the
judgment is fine. But if it's not,
what if he has a relationship
with her kids with her?
Oh No. You know, what am I saying
it's true or not. If it's true,
it's definitely true. That's right.
That's right. It's the moral judgment.
It's like if she became a woman
and that's what she really wanted,
and that's what he really wanted.
Is that a bad thing? You know,
everybody wants to decide that it is and
I think you know ultimately that's the
snap judgment and that's the one
that I would take. I would go, oh,
he's a fucking creep. That's his
daughter. I hate to say this,
but when we're dealing with what you
should and shouldn't be able to do and if
ultimately this is what two adult people
want to do, it sounds disgusting to me,
but I don't feel like it's
within my jurisdiction to
tell adult people what they
can and can't do together,
whether it's a brother and sister.
Her brother and sister are in their
forties and they started decided to start
fucking each other. Why
do I care? The only,
the only reason why I would care as if
they decided to make children and it can
be some harm to the children. Why is it
a law against them fucking each other?
I mean I don't, I don't want to do
it to my sister. I love my sister.
She's my sister. It would make me
feel disgusting to have sex with her.
I've never thought about it once. But
if you do, what do I give a fuck can,
can I tell you why I don't care if I had
to, like I call it gun to my head go,
which way's better your way
or the way we do it now?
I always say go on that way
because every time we evolve,
we don't look past and may think we made
any mistakes. And you know what I mean?
Never went. You know the one group
we were too fair to. Who knows?
Like it just seems like it always,
the story's going to be most
likely everything you're saying.
And like who knows what
year there'll be like,
there'll be some kid off to go wet.
It used to be wrong to date. Your,
your brother told be like, yeah, I
mean years or they would the, you know,
they'll tell the
story and she about who you fuck.
Yeah, no to me. And it's funny than me.
And you both need to say
because it doesn't have,
it doesn't have interesting introspect.
If it's interesting to one of us to think
of having sex with my brother fucking
at the group. I don't get
where I'm at by the, I get by.
That's what everyone else
does. They think, well,
I wouldn't want to have sex with
that person. So that was be gross.
That's what people think of gay people.
So I'm,
am I turning around and doing that to
another group right now? I don't know,
but fuck it. I'm Aaron on your side and
going leave everybody the fuck alone.
I think as long as you're dealing with
two sober adults, that's, you know, I got,
whenever I'm high and I talk about stuff,
I get nervous.
That would be the one detail that I would
look like an idiot if I go, wait, Todd,
that was between this age and
that age go, oh my God. No,
I was thinking of consenting
adults, consenting adults. Uh,
yeah, 18 and over you, you know,
mistakes are no mistakes. You're,
you're certainly going to make them.
You're responsible for a certain amount
of your actions from a certain age on
you. You should. You should. It
should be very difficult to trick you.
That's what we try to do.
We tried to make it legal to fuck you
when it's really difficult to trick you.
Really, people should be able
to fuck until they're 30 okay.
It should be illegal to fucking under
that standard. I'm petrified right now.
I'm sorry I wasn't listening
because I'm petrified to think.
Did I just say that being gay
was like fucking your brothers?
No,
I didn't say that right now.
You said that that's how some
people would feel about being gay,
that you, you as a gay man, a repulsed
by the idea of fucking your brother,
but some people would think
about that as gay sex. You know,
just just have a brother and sister.
Make it brothers and sisters. No,
it's a perfect analogy because why does
anyone care what two people that are
adults decide to do, whether it's two
women or two men or for women and six men?
Who cares if they are all in agreement
and they all are consenting and
everybody's sober and no one gets tricky
because there's plenty of people making
psychological mistakes by who
they date it, whether it's so,
whether even if it's cause it's a guy
and a girl there. There's other, yeah,
a million reasons. So this is
one more, maybe you shouldn't
do it. And why it's, I,
I was sort of halfway knew I was
going and then I got lost. Well,
the idea of someone being able to tell
someone else what they should enjoy,
whether it's sex or music or
anything, right. Even if we write,
if you're a person who likes
getting your feet sucked,
you love it and everybody else
thinks it's fucking disgusting. If,
if someone else like sucking feet and
you two get together, that's awesome.
You know,
immediate might freak you out if that's
your next door neighbor and you're like,
hey, just sucks feed all the time.
They go over the guy's house,
his feet all over the wall
and it's fucking feet phones.
He's just a crazy flood soccer,
you know, don't get no one.
You know what I sort of,
what I sort of get from what you're saying
right now is that like, and it's good.
I like to remind myself,
I figured myself as lead everybody the
fuck alone and don't judge everybody and
just, I know they think as long
as maybe I catch myself doing, oh,
of course you can have limitations where
you can say there's obviously that's a
two consenting fucking adults. But maybe
even though I think I'm open minded,
you're right like that, you
know, why would make judgment
on someone you're right.
Maybe or make stupid jokes like that
to what you were just talking about.
The foot sucky, but what, why the fuck
I don't want to be that person. Yeah.
He likes feet.
Somebody black stocking feet.
I don't want to be the person who
goes, hey, you know that guy. Yeah,
it's weird.
We all do it.
I think we do it also because we're
insecure and because it's also not even
necessarily, and it's, it's,
it's a jump reaction that people have
to something that's very different from
them.
And guess what?
If you found it out and I'm saying maybe
someone hearing this would be like,
you know what? I might do
that, but now I'm not going to,
here's what it is like you don't want
to be that person that goes, hey,
you know that guy for no reason at all
and found that out about that person.
Two years later you're still going. Yeah,
he's a good guy. He likes slugging feed.
How do you know how some picture
got published and you don't?
Why would you want to prepare? Why do
you have to keep telling everybody that?
Why do you now look,
I don't like sucking feet and I don't
want everyone to get nervous. Your me.
Oh, that's a joke. I was doing a
sketch feet and a sketch schedule,
like if you had a picture that was an
old SNL audition that I used to make my
own tapes was this thing I used
to do. That's hilarious. So funny.
Jesus, I'm leaving. I'm
going to leave. I'm going to,
I'm going to leave it more people alone.
That's all I want to do.
That just saying it's fine. You're not
alienating anybody with foot soccer's.
Oh yeah. That, I know. It's a small
segment and you don't have to worry.
They could laugh at it. That's my rule.
Like I think I tried it here to that,
like someone that did suck feet could
listen to this, you know? Yeah. And laugh.
Yeah. I don't think they're
going to be offended.
I think we're pretty much
giving them the green light.
Thank you for giving everybody the
green light is that you're not hurting
anybody else,
but it's one of those things where like,
have you ever told someone that you
like a certain thing and they go, oh,
that fucking sucks, but it doesn't
suck to me. Do you know? I like it.
I actually do like it. I like this
band. I liked that. And like food. Yeah.
It's like so many things
that were comfortable to talk
about that we don't like.
No one has to be lie. They like
Italian food, but some areas it's like
you have like Kimchi, get the
fuck outta here. You like Kimchi,
they'll get mad at you. You like Kimchi.
I'm like, go. I buy it. I like it.
It's delicious. Leave me alone. No, I
mean like fuck is wrong with you bro.
You're eating Kimchi over there.
It would never do that if someone goes,
you got to read you like a red car.
People live. Yeah. Yeah, like different.
Red is a little tricky,
right? It's a little douchey.
Why? I don't have a red car.
A red sports car. Almost got
one. Did he never had a red car?
What color is your car? Just getting
a red core colors. Your car. I silly.
I get silly. What color is white?
What kind of car? It's a Porsche.
And is it a of Kuwait? I
wouldn't even ask. I was going
to say, is it a four door?
No, no, no, but they make
those now. I know. I know.
Here's the, here's the thing.
I thought like, you know how when
you don't know? I don't know.
Like it seems to be, it was one person I
knew that likes Porsches were like, no,
that's not cool. And then I thought, Oh,
do people think they're not cool but not
knowing. When I just saw one, I was like,
fog,
like I don't even not,
it's not the type of car usually
like just looked like a cool sedan.
I didn't know it was a portion
until I looked. There's a problem
people have with a rich people,
items like that and that
they automatically dismiss
them as being a douchey
thing to have because so
many douchey people on them,
but the reality is what they
are is marvels of engineering.
There are these amazing creations by
these geniuses and artisans. I mean,
to me that's what it is. It's an
expression of art. It's geometric art,
it's functional mechanical art. They
figured out how to make this exciting,
exhilarating thing that performs in a
way that other cars don't and it looks
great. It's like a cool, sleek, like
I liked the way they designed it.
I think it's a beautiful
piece of engineering.
No,
it's funny you mentioned that because
there's something I'd probably do like I
sometimes, like we've talked about on
the show that I wouldn't want to pull up.
There's a lot of cars where I do my
show. I looked down on these cars. Oh,
there's so many that I fucking love.
Like I could just,
I get it to sightlines.
I'm more of an SUV guy I think,
but I can look at so many of those,
but I wouldn't drive onto the Improv
because I've said this on my show.
I go because I don't know you,
but what the fuck? Why? Why?
That's like doing exactly the
opposite of what I preached to do.
It's like an eye prejudge. I
do. I prejudge instead of, but,
but I know that's person might drive
it up for the same reason that I sit
upstairs and look down at the cars and
go, fuck, look at that one. Look at that.
We go over and we touch in the
paint feels different therapy,
but yet I would be afraid to do it.
Well maybe you shouldn't be the Mar.
I'm going to buy a Dune buggy.
But if that's the car that's one of those
crazy VW bugs and has like the extra
wide fender flares,
engine exposed,
drive around with that convertible.
It's the one I like crazy.
Joe Rogan told me it's all right.
It's painted whatever fucking color.
You're like a bubble machine. I've
gotten out of it. Could Joe Rogan.
It's a inside of it.
It's constantly blowing bubbles.
Little sound.
Todd glass ladies and
gentleman pulled up to his spot
when Todd told me, you know,
this is you going when?
When Todd told me he, I appreciate car.
I thought he meant like an old Porsche.
I didn't know he's going to get that.
He's blaming me. I mean, yes technically,
but Dune buggy with a
full roll cage I wanted,
I was so jealous in my neighborhood
when someone had a dune buggy.
This guy's got a dune buggy. The bottom
of the ocean. Is that what this is?
Beetle a beetle cage car where they can
drive around on the bottom of the ocean.
Oh, that's hilarious. Cade says
sharkskin kidding. That's incredible.
Oh my God. What a genius idea would have
a little shark swims in their bites.
You right in the Dick and is playing
a holes and that fucking thing.
They're crazy. Yeah, there I wouldn't
need weapons and Kevlar. What do you do?
I have, I've, you know,
the whole seaworld thing that's
going on that hate it. Have you,
I hate the idea.
I've spent too much time paying attention
to killer whales and dolphins and
reading about them. I hate it. Let me ask
you a question. It's Pr, it's slavery.
It's slavery to an alien animal
that we don't understand.
What do you do with people
that like if they can look,
there's some things I do that make me
hypocritical and I'm asking you to help me
fight the fight. What do you do with
this? Because you know someone would go,
what about, so I agree with the, I agree
100% it's like no, come on. Like, well,
the way we will treat them as the way we
treat each other, it's more than that.
Even if it's just not that it
has to do with it, but it does.
Even if it ended right there and that
animal's pain and it didn't affect the way
those humans that can do that, treat
other people on that alone. It's wrong.
But don't think your for a second that
that's not also if you have the ability
to do that, you're not bringing
home a good energy to your kids.
Those people that fucking do that,
they go home to children,
they pass that there's something vial
and unaware of a human thing to slug it
in. Now what do I do with people that
go, you eat meat and that's the way it's
what I've set up till now is this.
I go,
I don't want to be a smoker that
smokes and because I can't quit,
I want to be the smoker. I was, I
used to smoke and while I smoked it,
but this is such this, I knew
it was violent, disgusting.
I didn't think why don't
have the ability to quit.
So I'll make pretend to give a
public outward thing of going, ah,
you know you're going to have, you can,
you can eat a candy bar to not, you know,
you know there's people that write
it off because they can't quit.
I just called the vial and that
led to me quitting one day. Right?
So I want to do the same thing with the
meat just because I'm lazy or whatever
it is right now,
and I might be partaking in some of that
slaughtering the way I eat every day.
It doesn't negate that I know it's wrong.
And Sea world thing like come on.
How can someone think that's okay with
Joe and some of your listeners, you know,
might disagree with us. Just like
the seaworld thing. You just,
when you hear the facts and
the size and you get it,
it's a bath tub and that they take,
so take away from his family and all that.
What listening person right now,
and I mean that wholeheartedly is
sitting home going, oh, it's seaworld.
Come on now.
You're being ridiculous.
Worse than prison.
Okay.
Because it's being imprisoned
by an alien species present.
At least you could talk to the guards.
It's,
it's an insane relationship that they
have those killer whales have with those
trainers and it's, it's
atrocious. The idea is insane.
They are incredibly intelligent.
They have a very complex
language that we can't decipher.
They have different accents for different
regions. They recognize each other.
They have very tight knit colonies.
He stayed together forever.
We just can't appreciate the
way they live their life.
But their world is a magical wonderland
where they're the top dog of the sea.
They kill sharks, man. They got their name
killer whale because they kill whales,
they kill small whales.
They'll go up to like a a humpback whale,
have a child and they'll tear it apart is,
I watched a horrible video of
it the other day with these,
I mean we like to think of Orcas as
being these like really sweet things that
jumped for fish. They're
murderous machines when
they're out there in the wild.
They killed dolphins on a regular basis.
But for them,
that's the spoils of the real world.
That's how they to the top of the
food chain by being these ruthless
superintelligent motherfuckers that
live in this playground of the ocean and
they cheat,
they migrate up and down the coast
and they've done so for thousands and
thousands of years until this
fucking tiny blip in time.
This industrialized age,
this age of aquariums is age where they
figured out how to capture those fucking
things. And stuff them into
fucking swimming pools.
It is slavery.
It should be highly illegal.
The people that want to do it, it
should. It should without a doubt.
They should tax them out of fucking
business. There should be no way.
You should be able to profit off
taking a thing and making it do tricks.
And when you find out how they train
them and you hear the things they do,
they isolate them and put them
in small tanks they put there.
It's way crazier than putting a
person in solitary confinement.
They have them all stuffed together
physically. They can't fucking move.
They wind up biting each other
and aggravation. It's slavery.
It's just slavery of a nonhuman,
but equal level intelligence.
We have this idea that just because
they can't alter their environment with
their fingers, that they're not super
intelligent, but that's our own biases.
They're insanely intelligent.
In fact,
their cerebral cortex is something like
40% larger than a human beings that we
don't know what the fuck they're going,
what's going on in their mind,
but they're absolutely aware that what
we're doing to them is not what they want.
They want to be fucking free and
just because he charged money say,
well it's going to go to conservation.
You know what else would go
to conservation awareness?
Let people know what a magical
animals and the people will donate.
By the way,
whenever I hear more on podcast where
we'll ask those type of questions, I go,
who? I always go if I had a show and
people go, you do have a show. I go, yeah,
but I mean it got near the people
that I want to ask the questions.
How come nobody has told them yet?
And better way than I could tell as this,
but no one I've never asked.
So one interviewer,
when they're interviewing these people
that say, well we give a lot of money,
would you be able to molest a group of
children but then give $7 million a year
to the cause of molestation to,
cause it's not a race it no,
it's like they actually through such as
like doctor Phil calls a paper argument.
Like you're, you're making an
argument that's not really being had.
Like you're trying to act like the
argument is why do you give money to,
that's the argument also for hunting.
You know the argument for hunting is that
when you hunt you the hunters pay for
tags and those tags pay for conservation.
And in fact hunters do like better.
They,
there's more money that
comes to conservation for
preserving animals that come
from hunting than I think almost any
other source is hunting bad. No, no.
Not only is it not bad, it's important,
right. That's what I thought.
That's what I miss the levels of the car.
If you've ever been on a road and
like Wisconsin or some shit like that,
like late at night, you have to manage
that. Like people are gonna die.
Like unless you introduced
predators into the environment,
unless you introduce wolves, which
is equally dangerous, you know,
and we're starting to
see the results of that.
There's people that are
getting attacked by wolves.
A guy was a hunting with his friend and
they had a fight off the fucking wolf
pack is really recently and there they
were trying to fight over an elk carcass
and it becomes a real issue and they
dominate areas and they don't take kindly
to some new hunter coming in. There's
a video I put up on Twitter. Um,
guy runs into wolves while elk hunting.
I put it up a while ago.
Just look up on Youtube, uh, ran
into wolves while l cog, elk hunting.
And there's this, I'm always
fucking crazy video. These dudes,
elk hunting in these wolves are around
them circling them how old and shit.
It's fucking eerie. And they're
like, oh shit. But they have guns.
They're not freaking out too much, but
they're like, oh shit, this is crazy.
Like the wolves, like following
them, looking around at them.
Like they would here one over there and
then would one would run through the
woods in front of them. It was
really fucking weird. Uh, coyotes,
uh, that's what we see in
Los Angeles. Or is it wolf?
When I see a coyote on my street, if it,
if it, if it's anywhere near my house,
like especially in front of my house,
uh, I will rather, if I had the money,
I would go check into a hotel because
I'm always afraid when I get out of the
car, they're going to be lurking out of
every tree around my house. So it's like,
I just pictured that I get creeped and I
though I bolt from my house to my front
door. You should, they give me the
boat. I just got bitten Colorado.
A guy got attacked by
coyotes at a bus stop.
I liked the [inaudible] wolf hunting
surrounded by wolves with a bow. That's a,
this is the, it's the first one. You
know, I see this Brian w w wolf hunting.
Yeah. Listen to the fucking sounds.
These things are making these guys, uh,
we're out there hunting and the wolves
started circling them and finding out
where they were and like communicating
with each other. They like,
one of them would pop out and they were
like staring at the dude's and then they
would go back into the forest and
another one will come from a different
direction. They're all making these crazy
noises, man. It's really fucking bad ass.
They're hungry enough, right? Oh,
they'll kill you for sure if they
think they get away with it, but they,
they're very aware of these dudes. And so
they're, they're letting these dudes, no,
first one was white. It wasn't,
but they have their guns.
How about now? They have bows and arrows.
How different are they from the sketchy?
Dangerous. Jody's much, much, much
bigger. Much bigger. Much stronger.
Much scarier.
Much smarter.
They eat coyotes all the time. Like
goldfish. No, no, no, no, no, no.
Coyotes are sneaky Fox man.
They're very sneaky.
And they figured out how to
get over over fences and shit.
Coyotes figure out a lot of ways to, uh,
to get into your, they get into my yard,
man. They got it into my yard. And I have
a, I have a high plans at the big one.
Yeah. So he's a blowing an elk horn
to try to get them to come over.
And that might've been what they
responded to in the first place.
They blow these horns, that sounds,
they have two different ones.
One of them that sounds like a male elk,
which is kind of scary.
And another one that sounds
like a female or a baby.
And that's what brings the wolves around.
Sure.
These guys are going to soon
have wolves around them.
They have holes around him right now
or they do it. They're making these,
there's still,
these fucking assholes are still making
these calls cause their elk hunting,
they're looking to get an elk,
but they're not going to get elk right
now because there's wolves everywhere.
There's a thing going on right now
in part of the country where they've
reintroduced wolves because the
wolf population had been decimated.
So they reintroduced walls button. They
used a larger Canadian wolf to like, uh,
you know, that's like using
Germans instead of pygmies.
You know what I mean? Like their bosses,
wolves. But one of them's mother fucker.
That gets to be about 200 pounds.
And so these things,
these big ass wolves have been
decimating these elk populations.
So that's your options. If
hunting, if you don't want hunting,
you have to bring in wolves. I'd say
we're probably safer with the hunting.
No, I always knew. Matter of fact,
I was surprised because I always
thought I couldn't hunt myself,
but I always knew that,
that I had thought that that was
always a good way to like that's a,
that's an honest and animal has a life.
It doesn't suffer. I know I couldn't.
They get killed.
But you're talking about in the
plants where an animal is whole life,
the dates killed is
the best day it's life.
And not only that, the, yeah,
the life is absolutely, you know,
absolutely wild as nature intended,
nothing changes until that one
moment you get shot. Right.
So it is the freest of
free range possible.
And a lot of times they've
never even seen a person before.
And a lot of times also you're
dealing with environments. Especially,
I went hunting in Montana and they
lose a giant amount every year.
Just they freeze to death,
they get killed by predators.
They freeze to death or they
get lame and if they get lame,
that get killed by predators.
I mean there's a lot of
different predators in that area.
And we found mountain line shit and it
was a log of mountain line shit and was
filled with hair. So it was a deer hair.
So they, that's how they get that go.
They use the freeze to death of
the killed by mountain lions.
They're not gonna make it. No one makes
it, no one, no deer die of old age.
It doesn't happen. It doesn't exist. So
it's just a matter of who kills them,
whether it's a Predator
or whether it's a human.
This fucking thing is dying
computers in a horrible way.
Do you know what?
I didn't realize what you just said until,
I don't remember what year it was,
but it was in my adult life.
Like I always had this
visualize, visualize an animal,
a certain age, you know,
they grow. Go what you just said, I
sorta realized once and I went, oh,
they didn't do any. I mean
statistically do any, no,
it makes it makes you maybe
elephants the so just,
and I don't know if you know the, you
know, just get me in the right area.
I'll be happy. Like, so let's
say you're a, I want to,
I don't want to pick an animal too far up.
How long's the deer live?
Oh, if it's lucky, it gets five years
then it's got to be really lucky though.
Oh really? Lucky. Super Lucky. And
then as it gets like six and seven,
they get old and haggard and
then something takes him out.
Either they break a leg, hop a
fence, and they freeze to death.
That happens all the time.
All the time.
Especially northern areas
or predators get them.
If they break a leg in California,
they're not going to freeze to death.
But you know,
they'll probably get killed by something
that comes along and finds them.
You know how they say, if it's Cliche,
it's true. Nature can be cruel.
As you're talking, as
you're talking, I'm like,
half of this I'd never even would
think of, I was like, forgot about the,
they get old, they fall over. It's
like nature can be fucking cruel. Well,
not only that,
there's also amount of limited
food supply depending upon the area.
That's one of the things that
conservationists do best. Um, and uh,
including these, um, game wardens
and other, the fish and game,
they figure out how much land there is,
how much food there is,
how many animals can be sustained,
and then what is the population?
And then they release tags
based on those estimates.
So it's the whole idea behind
it is managing populations
and they pull the pull
hunting back if there's any sort
of a problem, if there's any,
if the species are being extinct.
In fact, like big horn sheep, um,
when we were in Montana,
these fucking things are everywhere.
Everywhere you went hunting for deer.
But when we were there,
we saw more sheep than we saw deer.
But it's really hard to get a sheep tag
to kill a sheep even though there's a
lot of them because they're trying to
build up the population because they were
decimated at one point in time.
There was also, um, there's,
there's wolves there as well. Montana
wolves. There's, see there's coyotes,
there's mountain lions,
there's plenty of predators out there.
So they didn't necessarily need humans
to take care of this population.
They want to build it up to a substantial
size. You see that in Nevada as well.
What, what's the most amount?
Sounds like a weird question,
but what's the most amount
of animals you've, you know,
I mean like what you could say 50 or
a hundred running together in nature?
No Elk. You can see hundreds.
Have you? No, I've never seen it.
But in Colorado there's a town called
evergreen and we were visiting and there's
this area of evergreen is where this
main street is. And they have a photo,
I think it's on their web street, their
website. What's the most you've ever seen?
Uh, I, I've seen several
like deer together,
like four and five deer together.
I think probably the most I've ever seen.
I've seen,
um,
many times I've seen a moose
I've seen from five moose total,
you know, but not more than two
together. I've never seen a moose. Yeah,
I'm talking about it the other night
and we were saying, I swear to God,
we were what we were talking
about the Moose, how we, we,
we thinking are we thinking
of the cartoon Moose?
Are we actually thinking of the
Real Mousse? And we decided that no,
even the real loose, it's got some
crazy characters. Yeah. Like the,
you know what I mean? Obviously
they amplify it, but even the route,
so we pulled one up online.
I was like, Oh yeah,
that looks like something that shouldn't
be real. That's what I thought.
But someone told me that the nose, the
length of the nose. Did you tell me this?
No, the length of the
nose is, uh, because it,
it warms the air up before it gets to
the brain because you're dealing with
something that's so fucking cold.
The air is so fucking cold that
they have to have this long. No.
So as they breathe in the air,
it gets heated up slowly along the way
before it gets to their head because
they're dealing with like 50 below
zero weather. They don't hibernate.
I forgot about that. We're doing moose
where they ask, they're living in Alaska.
No, they live in Montana too. In
Colorado. Uh, where I was, uh, someone,
someone had moose droppings that
they had discovered. So they,
they get into Colorado.
There's this moose in several states,
but in Alaska they're really plentiful.
I wonder if, because you know, I mean,
keep in mind like, you know that lot
of people aren't that bright, you know,
a lot are, but some aren't. So these are
the ones I'm talking about. Like how many,
I don't want. If Moose
killings, when people,
people would see them would be higher
than other animals because dumb people go,
oh, it's a moose and not getting,
it's a row. She's animal.
Would people ever get to be near Mousses?
Yeah.
People die in Moose attacks all the time.
Is that true? Oh, so maybe I'm right.
Someone died recently in
Anchorage on the school campus.
I think a moose got in
and killed somebody.
They panic and they'll stomp you to
death if they're with their baby.
All I'm thinking of is the happy Moose
and I can't imagine them in a fit of rage.
Well, twice we stumbled upon, um,
Moose that had a child and we were super
careful about it. They're cute. Jesus,
the child is big, like a
fucking great Dane already.
And we know it's boring. Yeah,
I think the size of a great deal,
but it was, when we saw it, it was a,
it was obviously a baby, but it was still,
it was a big fucking animal, you know,
even though it was a baby,
but the mother was huge.
The mother was absolutely massive
and she just locked eyes with us.
They're pretty acclimated
to human beings and they're,
they're pretty sure of when people
are dangerous and when they're not.
But they also know that this occasionally
a bang sound that comes from people
and then one of their friends disappears.
Like they're aware.
They're not sure what the fuck is going
on, but there were a fucking people,
you know,
like if you're,
if you're ever in a place that has
like a lot of hunting pressure,
the deer are super skiddish. But
when you're in boulder, Colorado,
when you drive it around deer
just chilling on the corner,
like as the cars are going back and forth,
is it 10 point buck just chilling in
the corner eating grass from cars.
You're fucking flying
around all around them.
They don't give a fuck cause there's
zero pressure from hunters and they start
you. Yeah, like they
acclimate, right, right.
Boulder is crazy because I've
never seen a place like that.
I got out with my kids and you know,
I made sure that I stood in front of
them if the deer got really sketchy.
But usually they run away. They're
not, they don't try to be aggressive.
And the males especially,
except when they're looking for girls,
that's when they could be dangerous
towards the winter, uh, towards the,
like the fall of the Rut when
they start getting really horny.
If you cock block a deer, they'll
fuck you up. I would, I, I'm scared.
You know, I'm the biggest
chicken of, and I'm not, like,
if I could drive in the car, I would
appreciate it. But yeah. So I'm not,
I would be near it. I'm scared, you
know, when we should be. It's just,
that's a healthy
intelligence is what it is.
Every time I see a picture
up there and I don't like it,
it makes me paranoid of yourself. Yeah.
Okay, let's take it down. No, that's okay.
Why don't we don't need it. It's just
a distraction. News cast or hair. Yeah.
We can just shut it off, right? No, I
don't, I don't know. Logo on or something.
I don't want to freak you out. Oh,
it doesn't the audience see this? No,
the audience he's in no matter
what. We just don't have
to. Okay. See, there you go.
Yeah. Now, um, what were
we just saying about the,
um, about the Oh yeah,
so when I go to, uh,
you know,
DC where there's a lot of monuments and
the squirrels are used to people. Yeah,
yeah. Like that. Like, if I see a
score from a distance, by the way,
you know there's no more squirrels in
Lake Arrowhead. What? Isn't that weird?
What do you mean it? I almost,
when somebody said it, I
went, there's maybe less,
I don't know,
more squirrels and then I have somebody,
there was something that happened about
five years ago or seven years ago with
some disease that was up there. West
Nile type. I think that's what it was.
I'm not positive, but it's
the only thing like, you know,
when we hear about like for me, you
know, I always just hear about, you know,
like you just said, when they're
trying to save certain animals,
they cut off the hunting in certain areas
or we're trying not to kill whales or
you know, all that. But it was such a,
to see an example of it to
go after I realized that I
would start noticing, I go,
no, their score, maybe there's
less, no squirrels. Whoa.
It just not exist.
Like that shows you like the
magnitude of like just fuck.
And that's what happens to other animals.
Just don't notice it.
Oh from a distance. They're so
cute. My mom had a squirrel,
but she knew that when it was at a
certain age, he had to let it go.
She's like smart enough,
she's not going to be one of those people
with an animal that belongs in nature.
But she nursed it back to health.
She founded in her garage and
then she just let it on her patio,
but it wouldn't go anywhere and it
would just stay there. And you know, uh,
I forget what happened every time I've
told this story two times and each time I
forget what happened. But um,
she had it for a long time. Oh,
she gave it to a friend.
She, she couldn't,
it wouldn't leave her house and
she couldn't take it anymore. Wow.
Became the Mama and then the same
thing. Yeah. And then after that,
I don't know what happened. I got
hit by a bus. Oh, just kidding.
Why would I forget that
friends with wild animals though
when you take them in, is that the,
to reintroduce him back to the wild,
the super difficult.
They grew up getting food for free.
Like now. They got to go look for it.
Yeah, that's why it is. It
is. Yeah. You don't, well, I
don't know what you should do.
Squirrels.
Vegans of the rodent world. Oh,
they don't eat meat. No, they nuts.
That's why they're so sweet.
That's why you don't have to worry
about them like that. That's those cons.
Theat everything there. He fucking shit.
Elite condoms. They'll eat your deck,
Daddy. Whatever's in front of
them. Rats are assholes to me.
What you just gave legitimacy.
Now look, if I see any road in,
I get a little freaked out,
but when I see a rat in New York City,
here's what I think of their belly filled
with trash they found was Phil look
dead rats. Oh, they lead other routes. Oh
fuck yeah, they will. They
will be wrapped in Encino.
I lived in Encino and I had a rat
in my garage, a little rat problem.
I put my garbage in my garage before I
would put it outside. And these rats,
this apartment, those hills up there and
then see, no, they are infested with rats.
And this fucking giant rat
got killed in a trap. I mean,
it was fucking huge.
It was as big as this
thermostat's thermostats about
the body of the Thermostat
is about 12 inches long. It was a huge
rash, rat, splat everywhere it was.
It got, I get it. You know,
I had a big ass rat trap,
but it just smashed his
head and killed him.
But it was so big that I went
out there. I was like, whoa.
I was kind of freaked out. Well, I
said, I'll clean that up in the morning.
I was a bachelor, you know, Lazy Bitch.
I shut the light off. I shut the door,
I go to bed,
I get up in the morning and it's gone.
The only thing that's left is its tail.
They didn't need the tail.
They ate everything else. They
ate the whole rat. They found out.
They felt that they'd frown.
I was fresh meat.
There was their buddy and they were
like, good, this guy was a dick anyway,
let's eat. And they ate them.
And that's why rats are scary.
Rats don't even wait for you
to be cold before they eat you.
If you're their friend, they cannibalize
like on the Nache. It's normal.
That's how you get bought. There's no
like stigma about why. What are you doing?
It's just a squirrel.
Oh
it's this girl puts at a
golf game the other day,
took a squirrel out of the another guy's
pants and then put in a tiger was like,
why does the guy have a scroll
scrolling his pants? You're like,
just get an escort. And then I
thought he was pretty nice about it.
But you get the fucking
squirrel of my best friends.
His girlfriend isn't as girlfriend
girlfriend, I think that's his girlfriend.
She's a scroll lover. What can
you tell? What can you say?
Yeah, they've exceptable rodent. You
know what I mean? You can have a pet rat.
Don't get me wrong. Guinea pigs are a
little sketchy, but squirrels like, oh,
they're free and wild. But
yeah, their joke. You did.
The only rodents we see in the wild, we
go, aw, he's so cute. Which one swirls.
We have this attitude about them.
We have this APP will chips.
Thank God they got their tail. She
mocks or actually even cute or adorable.
When I was in boulder,
there was a lot of chipmunks out there
and we don't get the first step by that
either. No, we don't get into
it. And again, same thing.
But did they eat the same thing?
Rats. Yeah. They, no, no, no, no.
The chipmunks are like, they're eating
nuts. Nuts. The leaves of sugar. The rats.
Or maybe they're just because they maybe
if they wouldn't eat so much trash,
we wouldn't,
maybe we should tell them
stop eating trash and people
won't be as scared of you.
Well, they carry diseases
too. They absolutely carry
diseases. They carry rabies.
It wasn't, didn't rats have something to
do with the black plague? Didn't. Yeah.
Research that once. I don't think I could.
I know I couldn't. That's the thing.
I couldn't, if I, if I set a rat
trap, I could never go near it.
I'm like biggest chicken in the world,
but that stuff and I hate it.
Like I hate it.
Like one time I saw a bird flying to a
pool at a house I was house I was living
in when I first moved to
La and uh, it, it jumped,
it got into the water and I could have
run out and save it and like fucking
Clinton, it was a bird. I could have
reached in and gotten it and I couldn't.
So I was like, yell for somebody else.
I'm like, Hey, come on down to the pool.
There's the bird just flew into the pool
and the dot because it was too scared
shitless to go over and touch the bird.
Other people walk over at scoop it up.
Like,
you can't hate that about,
you should go to what you should
volunteer for. Like a petting zoo.
Get over that shit. Well, no, I'd
go to the petting zoo animals.
There's so numb and you need to
hang out with like, well, he's dead.
I was going to say
crocodile hunter. No, I don't want to get
back, but I liked it may not be screwed.
So
listen to this, the black death,
which is the w, this is the,
the rat disease killed an estimated 75
to 200 million people and peeking in
Europe through the years.
1348 to 1350.
Although there was several
competing theories as to the,
that's a lot. I ediology at
e I, T I o l. O. G y Mellon.
When I say that one of the black death
analysis of DNA from the victims of
northern and southern Europe,
published in 2010 and 11 indicates
that the pathogen responsible,
blah, blah, blah, year, uh, pursuing
bacteria and blah, blah, blah, blah.
Had somebody do a rats spread through
rats. I'm trying to figure out what,
Oh, here it is. Okay. It was carried from
fleas actually that lived in the rats,
oriental rat fleas that were living on
black rats that were regular passengers
on merchant ships. So it's spread
throughout the Mediterranean in Europe.
That's why they were so scared of rats
and black death decimated to kill.
Ready for this 30 to 60 60% of
Europe's total population that time.
So there's a reason they
have this reputation shoot,
some of it on a fairly though
percent of their total population.
You imagine if something came along and
wiped out six out of 10 of all of us,
I think it should have a mean or
reputation than it does. Oh my God.
You know what I mean? You know
you're a rat. It's not that bad.
It should mean despicable. It should
be very bad. Not just [inaudible]. Yes,
thank you. Should not just be told
on somebody. Yeah, you right. Well,
I think that's like, you
know, listen to this.
All in all the plague reduced the world
population from an estimated 450 million
down to 350 million in the 14th century.
[inaudible] this 14th century,
so 13 hundreds so it killed.
That's insane, man. It killed
100 million people at least.
Okay.
75 to 200 million people.
That's insane.
So hard for me to even
think about those years.
And apparently it lasted
forever. I mean, they,
they couldn't cure things back then.
It just would last for years and
years and years and years and years.
People kept dying of these horrible
fucking diseases and some people would
barely get through it and their main
immune systems would strengthen and some
people would just fucking
drop off like flies.
Did you know the washing of the,
you know your hands and everything was
sort of not agreed upon by everybody.
At first I babies for giving birth,
they didn't even surgery wash their hands
and it was almost like the people that
wash their hands.
That's why I'm saying Joe,
everything leads down to the same
thing just because people didn't do it.
Like there's those things today.
Don't be on the wrong side because
every time in history it looks stupid.
There was a group of people to argue with
him over washing your hands. Well yeah,
there's that thing going on today,
so err on the right side of it or the
story's going to be about what a moron you
work
well. This is a word, weird
denial about global warming. The,
to me is absolutely fascinating because
it's really one of the few arguments
that have anything to do with nature and
the nature of the world that have these
ideologies attached to it.
Liberal ideologies and conservative
ideologies battling it out and when I hear
conservative people say that it hasn't
been proven that humans are responsible
for global warming or that it's just a
cycle of life are oftentimes I talked to
them about it and they
aren't even paying attention.
The actual effects of global warming,
they have this vague idea of what
the impact of global warming is.
Their main concern is
defending conservative business
practices and conservative
ideologies and that's like where they
go to immediately to strengthened up the
gate and battle down for
argument and it's the, okay,
well who the fuck knows who's doing it?
Look at what's happening.
How much do you know about
what's happening? And that's
when you, it's minuscule.
These people have very little idea.
For the most part,
people are like really
passionate about the subject.
I'm sure there's a few experts out
there that disagree with be right now,
but I'm just saying that by
Mike personal experience,
a lot of people that I meet,
and I don't have an opinion on it because
I'm not a fucking climate scientist,
but I've talked to like 25 year old
guys, you know, they're like, you know,
hard asses and they're like,
look,
fucking Earth's temperature has been
trained in for, you know, a million years.
It goes up and down. The dinosaurs
lived in a totally different, okay,
that doesn't matter.
You know what else we know then?
We know that used to be an ice age to do,
you know that you know,
that half of North America was
under like a mile high sheet of ice.
But what we do know is it's
happening right now for sure.
Well, but let me ask, and this
might be a no shit type of a thing,
isn't the argument you would think on the,
on the people that think let's uh,
let's,
uh,
do what we need to do to do whatever we
can do isn't what you should do the same
whether you believe in we could
change it or whether you can't,
let's say you think you can't change it.
We can't fix it.
You would still want to respect the
planet while we're here so you can not
believe in it and still like I don't
understand what the argument is to not
acknowledge because isn't the whole
fight to like try to be more aware of how
much gas we use and right.
Isn't that the ultimate goal
to prove that it's happening?
Does that make any sense
to me? Totally. Me.
I thought we were trying to prove
let's use less because look,
the global warming is our way of proving
it may be making people believe it.
So that's where I'm confused is so even
if it's not, even if we can't reverse it,
what's the downside of doing everything
they say to do? Does that make sense?
How does that businesses would have to
change some of their parameters like car
businesses, you know, what did they
do if they have coal burning plants,
what do they do?
Like this is what real problems in parts
of China that the pollution has gotten
so bad from coal burning that
they literally can't go outside.
There was this insane video that they,
that was on TV the other day. Uh, let me,
let me pull this up. Smog in China.
It's a, it's fucking nuts, man.
These people are walking down the
street and they, they have their,
their faces covered with like masks and
stuff and they're trudging through and
it looks like they're in an apocalypse
movie. I mean, it's worse than the road,
you know, the gloomy look, that mood,
the road, this gloomy, apocalyptic world.
This is way worse than that. And people
live like, yeah, dude, it's, it's insane.
Like you couldn't make a movie like this
unless you added in later because you
couldn't expect the actors to
work in that kind of conditions.
If you made a movie about the apocalypse.
They have to, where's this at? China?
Look at China live that long, right? No,
they don't. They can't live long at all.
It's just, it's killing them for
sure. There's no doubt about it.
There's no doubt about it.
It's killing at a rapid pace.
It's probably taking decades
off their life record.
Smog levels shutdown. City of
Harbin, this is it. Pull it up. Uh,
Brian pull up smog in China and
it's the first video on, uh,
under videos in Google.
It's fucking crazy, man.
You're seeing these people walked on
the street and you're like, oh my God,
you nutty.
Fucks have poisoned your city to the
point where people can't even breathe the
air. And it's still, everyone's tolerating
it still. Everyone needs jobs still.
Everyone needs to feed their kids.
So they just let these businesses
continue to operate the way they are.
Everything.
They should divide all the food.
Everything should be shut down for a
fucking month. Just let the air clear out.
Jesus, look what you're doing.
Pull up the video, Brian.
Look what they're fucking doing. Look
at this. Look at this Todd glass. Okay.
Want to remember that? I look at it. Look
behind you. Look behind you. Look behind.
You can see it.
This is fucking madness.
This is a incredible,
incredible madness.
Well,
nine more than 20 anything above 300
I backed it up so that makes sense that
he's describing what's wrong with the
content.
Organization recommends daily levels of
particulate matter with a diameter of
2.5 micro meters to be no more than
20 anything above 300 is considered
dangerous levels. Around a thousand
were recorded in some parts of Harbin.
All schools were shut and the airport
was closed. Open. His home to sum it up
would have been still in your head
going up and Philly, California.
People don't understand that. No days,
snow days was the greatest thing ever.
Remember that boy?
98 one close.
We were 102 they go 103 and whenever
you were like skippy, be like,
shut the fuck up.
Remember you would call a number,
the add a number to call
for school closings.
I would tell you all the school closings
in a recording and they don't have that
shit anymore. There's
tweet it probably. Yeah,
I'm sure they probably send the parents
emails just on a mass email to all
students. That's such a great
one to think of like, Oh shit,
that is like another fucking snow days
are awesome. Did you hear about that?
I never liked school. You didn't
stay up? I see yellow bus.
I get a stomach ache. What?
Well, University of Iowa teacher,
a teacher assistant sent
out her whole entire class.
She was supposed to send out
like the answers to that thing,
but sent out pictures of her and
her boyfriend masturbating. Oopsies
Iowa, Iowa. Woopsies so this is what
happens when you fuck around with email.
You don't know what you're doing.
Those snow days were fucking awesome
on one second. Do you think that woman,
I know, do you think she
should get fired for that? Oh,
but what do you think the masses thing,
you think in that community?
People are quick to judge.
They're hypocrites.
She's taking a picture of her
father didn't. So what? Yeah,
she is definitely an accident
and obviously she's probably,
I mean unless she's Cuny
love, we might be wrong. Okay.
We might be assuming it's an accident
and she might be just be like
really a crazy attention person.
It was like this is the way
I'm gonna get attention.
I'm going to send him pictures of
me jerking off. That's possible.
To course we limit that, but that's
not, yeah, we shouldn't necessarily,
I think you should leave all possibilities
open up cause we don't really know
her. I mean we limited when we're deciding
if it's all right or not weeks. Yeah.
Okay. Excluding that. No, that was
her story holds true then. Yeah.
So of course she should keep her job.
People are so fucking judgmental
and hypocritical. She's a woman who,
I mean d depending upon of course your
actual performance as a, as a teacher,
let's just assume she was a great teacher.
If it was a great teacher,
also loves playing with her pussy.
What do you give a shit? What?
You know the parents that would
have a real problem with that.
You're completely unrealistic and
if she's playing with her pussy,
she's having fun to me. She's going to
be nicer to the student masturbating.
So what? She feels good. It's
her pussy. She's off work.
You know she's not like
sitting on the desk today.
Kids are going to watch me jerk off.
Not a bill in front of them at first I
would like to have to fucking beat that
thing up.
A lot of people are more in channel and
they like to go with extra for the list.
I'm just telling you that one's going
to teach you this but I'm going to teach
you but don't tell your pants. I like
to spend my hands cause I feel dirty.
I want to just really beat it up
side to side tends to speed bag.
Just look to go onto the heart or
what are they writing things down?
What do you think they're telling
me? If you did that, first of all,
this is all in the the in real life, which
will never happen. What do you think?
You know enough about
enough about therapy,
but you can get pretty fucking close to
what we kids would do if you did exactly
that in front of a room full of children.
At what point would they go and may
potentially does it with her pants on so
it's not as gross. When we were
imagining it, well, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't say pants on. I would say
no panties to skirt. The kids do.
Seriously not to be funny, but what
rig out? They would freak out, right?
They would start to cry,
cry. Girls would scream,
and this is not wrong that I'm even
asking, is it? Oh No, not wrong at all.
I don't think they'd say, you
hoard. Some girls they would say,
well girl I grew up with would say, you
are. Oh, what age were you? 14 you know,
I'm talking about high school.
Yeah.
They would definitely know
that debts don't like that.
I brought this up. No, no,
no. I think it's important
that you brothers one judge.
The answer made me look crazy
because, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't know because if it's a good
question. Okay. Nights. In fact,
it's an interesting, it's, it's
weird. You know what? What'd you do?
What would you do? You think I'd take
out masturbate? I didn't say that though,
but I think there might be like a,
a desire to get close to her if like
this has happened more than once. Okay.
In high schools,
more than once.
Some young attractive teacher has had
sex with two or more boys from school,
either on campus, like locking the door
or take them back to her apartment.
It happens, it happens all the time. It
happens, I wouldn't say all the time,
but it happens.
It's happening several times in history.
Hearing about it more and more to it.
There's probably been half
a dozen or so that's being
really conservative examples of this
that have made it onto the news.
So we know that people are doing it.
You know, we, we know that we, we,
it's not like,
so you know,
to say that someone sends these naked
pictures of themselves woopsies I don't
know what I did.
Like she could be some crazy freak that
wanted to beat off in front of the class,
but they didn't want her to and she's
like, yes, she really did send it
to everyone in their class. Oh, she wanted
to do that. To not do it live but to,
it could have been.
I'm not excusing that
I, yeah, I do.
I do not know what her motivation was
or if it was actually an accident,
but if it wasn't an accident,
it is possible that there's a person
out there and not saying it's her,
but some person,
a person who's willing to fuck every
football player in her school and she's a
28 year old that's happened before.
If there's a person like that out there,
there's also a person that'll just email
her pussy out there and go woopsies.
Right. All my goodness. Did you
see my pussy? Did you like it?
What did you think about it?
I didn't mean to send it to you,
but now that you saw my pussy,
what'd you think by the way?
You basically in life get one
freebie. Yeah. And then after that,
thank God for keeping records leave.
I accidentally sent my
pussy to everyone again
the first time you're clear record.
I think everybody gives you the benefit
of the doubt and they should because can
you imagine,
by the way,
we're only saying the 1% chance that it
happened with some cray or 3% because we
know 97% she's horrified. She's a decent
person that just got out. It's like fuck.
And then there's people that judge you
were saying we don't want to be that.
Exactly. We definitely will. We'll
take a break. We'll be right back.
Joe Rogan is my guests this afternoon.
We'll ask him what he thinks of the new
healthcare program when we come back and
get into it and blah, blah, blah.
Dead. Clarifying your point
is very important to you.
I like that it is the one that's
not weird at all. It's thoughtful.
I think you're very thoughtful about it.
Yeah. I tried to like, uh, yeah, it's the,
it seems like I go backwards sometimes.
No, I mean sometimes you just
thinking about things like
you don't, you shouldn't.
Odd. Americ automatically have a very
fully formed opinion on certain subjects
everybody thinks they're supposed to.
And if you don't, you're an idiot.
But there's nothing wrong with
not having a fully formed opinion.
As long as you're honest about it.
I always say that I always say
the same thing. I'd go, yeah,
as long as you're careful to say it like
because uh, and I do, I try to go look,
I'm still taking in stuff cause I think
it lessens the anger if people at home
that really genuinely
might, no, you're wrong.
I feel like they always tell them be
comforted because if I get an email and
it's intelligent and somebody
breaks it down, you know what?
I think the first time I read an email
that educates me, I go holy fuck,
I want to do an earlier podcast cause
I want to come back on and go totally
didn't think about that. So knowing that
I will do that always lets me think.
Okay. I'm comfortable to sometimes
speak before I have formulated my, yeah.
Opinion.
Yeah.
It's important I think.
And it's important to be honest
about what you actually know,
what you don't know.
There was one of the funny things about
this midnight in Paris movie was that,
um,
his wife and the movie was a,
there was a guy saw in the clip was
just like super intellectual guy who was
like, you know, judging wines and he
was a real, you know, annoying dude.
And throughout the,
you saw woody
Allen like a woody Allen's character,
like battle with this guy about like
facts and ideas and deal with his, uh,
by bullshitting him, you know,
so it's, I dunno, I think,
I think it's important to let
people know what you actually do.
Now this movie, it was
pathetic. It was funny,
but Willy Alan was always pretending
that he had facts he didn't have.
Oh was that like the yeah,
he,
he would argue with this guy about some
things that he hadn't researched at all.
It was really fun. It was funny because
he didn't know what you get lost.
You're glad you come back.
Cause it's like what a great and that,
that movies out right now. Yes.
Well, I watched it on a plane,
but it was 2011 movies. So you could
probably get it on a, you know,
probably get it on apple TV or something
like that. We've all, we've all done,
we've all done that. Yeah. Yeah. There,
especially when you're young bull shit,
your brains out,
you know,
somebody posted on the message board
that and the pollution in Beijing,
it's pretty much identical to the low
Pittsburgh had in 60 years ago and posted
these photos. Oh, that's
crazy. But that could be fog.
I'm assuming it's not though. No, there's
a, there's a Jesus Christ that's real.
And that's in 19 what, 60 years
ago. Who uh, what's the guy's name?
I have vinegar taster and put
a link to an article. Wow.
That was, that was Pittsburgh not long
ago. Whoa, that's nuts. Oh my God.
Look at it on a map. That's, look
at that from the sky. That's insane.
Oh my God.
When you look at it from,
when you look at it from the top,
like from an airplane,
it looks like a big black cloud
or a gray cloud over the city.
That's bananas.
They cleaned it up all nice and good.
Oh my headphones. Pittsburgh or injured.
Is that because it's like the steel
city and they probably had shitloads of
steel factories and stuff like that?
Probably back when he's back. Yeah,
I would imagine. Yeah, I would imagine
that's a lot of what the pollution is.
You know,
whenever there's a bad,
in the past I remember in
school I would ask my teacher,
cause it's the only way I can visualize.
I had no concept of the 1300 so I would
ask her anytime we talked about an ear,
if there were stores, that was in my
head. That's what, and I think she,
she was always very nice to me,
but I think after a while I stopped
asking you because we're their stores.
Then they, I wonder if they even had
locks back then. They must've right.
[inaudible] but what they
have, when did, okay,
let's find out when was
the invention of the lock.
They used to have those keys like,
yeah,
let me know when you go to a hotel and
they still have the old key and you're
just like, really? You don't have a key
card again, that's always weird isn't it?
Isn't the police in
Austin, I'm thinking, okay,
the history of locks, I need
to know this. Okay, ready?
This the first serious attempt to improve
the security of the lock was made in
1778 the first loc was s woe ready for
this estimated to be 4,000 years ago.
It was a four runner to a
pin and tumbler type of lock,
a common Egyptian lock for the time.
That's insane. The lock work using a
large wooden bolt to secure a door,
which had a slot with several holes in
its upper surface and the holes were
filled with wooden pegs that
prevented the bolt from being opened.
So that was the first invention of the
LoC proving people that had been stealing
shit for years. There's no year
to go back to stealing shit.
Well also figuring,
figuring it out the need a gang of
people working on this kind of stuff.
In order to get things happening.
You know,
if you're going to figure out how
to make a wheel or make a car,
or maybe you need a lot of mother fuckers,
dude who knows how to make tires
figured out how to make rubber,
you need to do to understand suspension
components you need to do to understand
the combustion engine. How do you
get that into a a card? Make It, oh,
we need a transmission guy.
There's a lot of different variables
and one person's not gonna invent a car.
Yeah, but even when you,
yeah, that's, that's,
it's funny to think about like
someone I don't think about back then.
The process that goes into it,
like someone invented the wheel
because that was the forward thinker.
If that time, where was he writing his
stuff down? Like what year was that?
Does that, does that? When was
the invention of the wheel?
So did, they didn't have,
they couldn't have written then. By
the way, my, my history is atrocious.
So if I ask any questions
like what? No, it's all right.
You're not pretending to be an expert.
We're just talking.
Thank you Kaitlin and time as
we all right. I don't know man.
That's a good question. That's
what I'm saying. I, you know,
I always picture the worst. Uh, for some
reason in my head though, every listener,
like even though I know I'm crazy, is
this, no, he's talking about the map.
He knows nothing about the map.
Well, there's images of uh, it as,
as recently or as far back as 2,500 BC.
That was for what? For four
wheel. The invention of the wheel.
The earliest well dated
depiction of a wheeled vehicle.
The earliest is 3,350 BC.
It's a clay pot that has wheels.
Okay.
I'm not even joking when I ask this,
even though you would think
the answer would be no, I bet.
I Bet I'd be wrong for thinking
that the guy who had whatever,
you got things around before that probably
thought the guy with the wheel was
crazy.
Like he didn't see it in his head or
like now it's hard to imagine someone not
understanding a wheel. Well, that's,
that's pretty, pretty fucking incredible.
One of the old one was a square and then
things like that guys like it's a star
dirt good. You get good traction, you
need to take a break and then you keep it.
That's what the Jewish stock came from.
They drove around,
they put it on a stick and the guy sat
down there in the middle and the flicking.
Okay. I pushed him. It was great
for plowing fields as well.
You till the soil as he drove
it was good for agriculture.
It drove around these stars of
David's until someone say, hey,
how about you just make it fucking
around man, this fucking guy.
He knows everything. How are we going to
plow the fields if we have realm wheels?
They just drive around like an asshole.
Like wait, what? What are you doing?
You're going to make roads everywhere.
Is that what you're going to do?
You're not gonna, you're not gonna do
anything that's going to go in the dirt.
Are you going to make your own road?
How many roads
do you think not still with that is you
think the world is going to be covered
with roads all over the place.
You could just drive your stupid fucking
car that doesn't even drive over logs.
There's a lot. It's everywhere. How
are you going to make roads everywhere?
That's a stupid invention.
That's what they probably say.
Get the fuck out of here with this.
There's going to be roads everywhere.
Don't fuck Outta here. Get on your
horse and shut your fucking hole.
This is as good as we got bro.
It's very interesting.
It's really interesting.
Did they just take horse paths and
just kind of made them wider? No,
they had to fucking, they use tools.
There's a lot of times they use tools.
I mean you look it up.
So those old California roads
where you're going up the coast,
but you could tell they carved it
out of the, out of the row, the wall,
they're like carved the CARF tunnels
like in northern California especially.
They carved holes through the, through
the buildings, through the, uh,
through the rocks.
And we're talking a long time ago,
they did that shit a long time ago.
They carve paths around
mountain tops 200 300 years ago.
They did it a long ass time ago.
They did it before there was any cars.
They did it when there was wagons.
They would just, they would,
they would grade the ground. They would
cut it and you know, smash it down,
roll it with things.
They pulled things with horses.
They tried to get the ground is soft
and flat and straight as possible but
barely, and they only did it
like here's where the food is,
here's where we go to sleep and
this is where we got to work.
Let's get this and that and this and
then everybody stayed in that area.
He didn't go anywhere back then.
You didn't get in your fucking horse
and buggy and go to Arizona where taking
the cad, the kids are going to
go to California for the weekend.
You ever see those bells on the side of
the 101 I don't know if you've ever seen
it.
There's these bells.
Are they just hanging on the side of
the one on one and your dad the fuck is
that every mile. Really?
Yeah. And it's like,
I always wonder what it was and that's
the actual original path that they,
they had dug down and
they kept the bells there.
And that was back when it was horse
and buggy. Horse and buggy. Yeah.
They made some roads with horse and Buggy,
but you know,
people lived on the coast. Um,
most of the time there was some,
some towns in the middle where somehow
or another people got there because of
the trains or something along those lines.
But when it was pre pretrained like way,
way back 17 hundreds and shit,
they came in boats. Let, let me ask
you this then. So like let's say this,
this is a, they start this
village somewhere, you know,
was there still a higher key
of who doesn't do as much
work as other people are
at that course? That's always existed.
Does, it's crazy to think so. What,
like the person that would stop and not,
maybe they get the ride the
horse or something. It'd be like,
it may pretend job for them.
I think people died off easier that way
because people didn't want to breed with
them. And I think it's, it's,
it's certainly always been a looked down
upon aspect of people's personalities,
but it's also super fucking common man
because a lot of lazy bitches out there
and there's a lot of people that don't
understand how that being lazy like that
is so bad for you in every way.
You're never going to achieve
anything you ever want to.
He never going to meet your expectations.
You're never going to improve.
He never going to like feel like a real
sense of like accomplishing things.
He's just lazy. He never gonna to put out,
you're never going to really go for it.
And that's it's,
it's there for you to see so that you
could see how gross it looks to other
people. So when you meet
someone, I think, you know,
you meet someone who's troubled,
oftentimes the,
it's one of the best things that you
could see without having to go through it
yourself if you apply it.
Yeah. If you see what makes,
makes it feel weird about you? Like
I don't remember who said this. Um,
I think it was mark Twain or
one of those fucking guys.
He said a fool learns from
the mistakes that he makes.
A wise man learns from the mistakes
of others. Yeah, I love those.
Yeah. What does it great there? They're
great because they say so much. It's so,
yeah, that's a big one. And that
was one that was a great one.
I think it was mark Twain to me,
who the fuck knows who it was?
It might've been Benjamin Franklin.
Somebody great.
Some old bad motherfucker
[inaudible] of the long time ago.
Wrote shit down and so crappy paper.
Is it,
did you ever even think or would even
be something you'd want to think of if
somebody said like, you know,
what's a quote? You know,
you can get it to go down or they're
doing a wall of quotes and they call you
and you get to have one of your
quotes up there with all the,
I would go over a picket
never in a million. Oh, that's
right. You can't pick it.
Yeah, you would never, that's
like giving yourself a nickname.
The comedy medicine man. Hey, I got
Indian in feathers or how I go, Hey,
I'm here to do at Sharman ceremony.
I'm the comedy medicine man.
He can't nicknamed me. She was
jealous of those guys. Oh God.
Do something off my thing be
that's why I bought them.
Maybe there's somebody in the business.
You know what?
Maybe we can pick your own quotes and you
can, I want to say this one thing now.
I put this on my Twitter and um,
some people still keep retweeting it.
There's a,
um,
a thing that somebody attributed
to me that was not my quote at all.
It was a quote by a drag.
Geraldo and I tried to tell people
like when it, when it happened, I,
I tweeted it, but the core, there's
like a picture of me and it says,
this homeless guy asked me for money the
other day and I was about to give it to
him. Then I thought, he's
not going to use it on drugs.
He's just going to use it on drugs and
alcohol. Why should I give it to him?
Then I realized that's what
I'm going to use it on.
Why am I judging this poor bastard?
That's, it's actually Greg draw though.
Somebody got, must've gotten him confused
with me and attributed that quote too.
Yeah. But that's not my quote. He was
a really, really fucking funny guy too.
Greg Geraldo was, uh, uh, a good dude too.
I knew him way back in the 1990s.
He was out here doing his own TV show
right next door while I was doing news
radio. So, you know, we were super
friendly. He's a really nice guy. Really,
really fucking smart guy too. That's a
great, that's a great joke too. Yeah,
it's fine. Well, you know, that's his
style. You know, it's totally even,
it sounds like, are Geraldo
joke. I didn't know him well,
but it's almost says more about
that type of comedian and,
and the good part about comedy because
I love Comedians. Yeah, me too.
And I love it. I love comedians and loved
comedians too. It's, it's, it's, uh, I,
I appreciate that because it's,
it is,
it is something I really try to be
aware of how lucky I am to be like,
even though I'll complain about
some of the ones that don't, like,
it's never a new comedians
that I complain about.
It's just really old bag comedians that
do have no desire to change. I'm not,
so that's my number one problem. It's
not, it's not a new guy that might change.
I don't,
I don't judge a new guy that acts like
another comedian cause you know what,
he might grow out of it.
I've seen comedians and emulate other
comedians and then you look at him two
years later you go, oh they came into
their own. I don't judge in the beginning.
I just root for it all. And I'm positive,
very similar to musicians to do that.
Really? Yeah. Because so
anyway, when I talk about that,
the guy that's doing it for like that, but
this all started positive. But overall,
I love comedians and I and and it's a
great fraternity to be a part of and most
of them were pretty decent, pretty
soft and pretty cool and pretty honest.
You know, you hang out, you
feel you feel good around them.
I love Dom Irrera and one of the things
I love about Domino Rera is dom I rera
is always working on his act always.
He truly loves comedy.
It's not just what he does for a living.
He truly loves doing comedy and
he works on it all the time.
He hasn't ever hit the get ups, give
up switch. Some guys just hit that,
give up switch and then they start
complaining and you're around them.
They complaining about the business.
The business keeps screwing guys
like me and you're like, dude,
I haven't heard your sat in forever.
I haven't seen a special
out of you and forever.
I haven't seen you haven't
seen a website that's out.
I haven't seen blogs you've written. I
haven't seen a podcasts. You've done.
I haven't seen a fucking
let them in appearance.
I haven't seen anything from you.
You stopped.
You stopped doing comedy and now
you're whining like shut the fuck up.
Go and do it. And they're a
drag man. They're fucking drag.
There's such a big difference
from complaining cause I
know someone taking this
out of context.
I mean including me going,
I love to complain about a clubs that
don't get it or when they don't set it up
right.
But that's not my majority.
I also spend a shit ton of time
talking about good and positive things.
But the other guys there,
well after a while it's hard to
be around them because you like,
you have to do a lot of head nodding
and you think at one point don't they
realize I'm not agreeing because they get
to the point where I can't agree on it.
You're beating, you taken a near
beat. Yeah. They just beat you down.
What do you just give him a little
bit of that and they accept that? Oh,
those guys are brutal. There was a guy
that, uh, I was friends with that I,
I had to stop those back in the day.
I was friends with them for a long time.
Like I met him in the 90s and uh,
he did not do well.
He moved out to Los Angeles and now
these are real insecure guy and real
problems with, you know,
trying to go on auditions,
who's trying to be a comedic actor.
I like the guy, I enjoyed him.
Like there was a percentage of the
time that I loved being around him.
I loved it when we were laughing
and joking and talking about things.
I loved being around him.
But then there was another part that was
maybe it was only 10 20% of the time.
It was an unbearable, it was
torture. And I tried to let him know,
I tried to say, lick man, you know,
I appreciate that you're struggling.
I pee appreciate you're out here
in California. And it, you know,
it's hard to make things happen,
but here's what you got, man.
You're a talented guy. You're a
talented guy, you're a funny guy.
Just keep doing it and you'll
figure out how, what it is.
You'll find a manage you an audition,
you'll make a set that goes onto it.
You're going to find it the most important
things that you're enjoying yourself
and you're out here, you know, doing
what you love to do for a living.
That shit never flew with him. Why is
this fucking guy is fucking guys on TV?
How come this fucking guy got a
development deal? You know what man,
I'm turning the TV. I'm seeing this
fucking guy with a show and I'm like,
maybe this is not the business for
me. Me, me, I'm in the wrong business.
I saw that fucking guy set.
This fucking guy was terrible.
Let me tell you something. I mean,
he was like open mic night. Terrible.
I can I can I tell you,
I told someone who by the way,
they're not that case yet.
And matter of fact of the half,
half of my life is being afraid
of saying any names. Um, this is,
this isn't even a bad thing. Like this
is actually giving this person, you know,
credit, right? But, um,
that they were aware of it,
but it has to do with what you're talking
about. Uh, uh, complaining but, but not,
not that,
not that bad yet,
but it could be going down that path
and maybe I want to help a little and I
said, let me ask you a question.
If some celebrity offered you, um,
I didn't know what figure to make up.
I go $10,000 a month right now.
Does 10,000 a week exactly. To
write funny tweets. He, you know,
it's a weird make pretend thing, but I
go, they call you on the phone. He goes,
listen, I want to start
tweeting more and you know,
my voice you'll given to me at the end
of each day. I'll pick a few. I like,
you know, it's a, it's a
good paycheck, but it's okay.
I'll give you a $10,000 a week,
whatever it would,
would you be able to do that you need?
No. No. I asked, what would you think? No,
go ahead. Handle. I asked him and he's, I
know he could. He goes, yeah. And I went,
well then write some for yourself.
Like did the,
why are you not that you at least
should be tweeting funny tweets now me,
could I do it? No, but I don't
want to get a job as a writer.
I don't think that's my strong point.
This person is so like, you know,
write some funny tweets.
I take advantage of what there is.
Well if you, if you just have a
couple thousand followers, okay,
let's say if you're a comedian,
you're struggling,
you've got a thousand
followers to see a thousand,
I guarantee you out of
those thousand people,
if you say something that's truly funny,
they're going to hit that retweet
button and it might be a slow trickle.
Where would it be?
Like a few other people get it and then
a few other people get and a few people
steal it and they'll just fucking
copy it and throw it. That's a,
that's a real common thing with
non known funny people with tweets.
But then people get found because of that.
Our friend Kathleen up in
Toronto slash lean on a Twitter.
She's uh, w we hung out with her and uh,
Toronto, she's just a Twitter comedian.
And she wanted to do standup, but she
never really did it. You know, we,
me and Doug Benson and who the
fuck else was with us up there?
I think I was Callin. Hmm. Maybe. Uh,
it was in Toronto. I don't remember.
Was it Ari? Whatever, whatever it might
have been. Ra, whatever it was. Um,
she was like, she's really funny and
now she's got a development deal.
She's like doing a show on MTV. Right.
All from Twitter. And we know people.
He's supposed to say that. And that's what
to say. Anything, I don't know. Is it,
is it supposed to be a known
Cognito? Whoops. Oh, you don't,
I didn't know man. You didn't,
can't tell me Shit like that.
And then it's supposed to be a seat.
No, no. Okay.
Whenever it ain't no people just got
my point is got like 50,000 Twitter
followers or something. She's
hilarious. Yeah. Yeah. People
are going to, and again,
it's not me saying that about myself
because it's for a tweeting is I tweet and
I like it. It's not my
strong suit. But this person,
if you're claiming you're right or anybody
out there that says they're a writer
should ask themselves the same question
like, yeah, fucking, you're right.
It doesn't mean you have 3
million overnight, but you
will see your numbers grow.
And obviously we, we, like I just
said, we see a lot of these people,
so it's just applying what certain people
do to your friends that don't realize
you could do it.
Here's what she said.
Here's our latest tweet her,
her name on Twitter is
Princess Anus and she writes,
turned on the little heater under my desk
at work crunching numbers and cooking
pussy.
She's showing her pussy like her
pants looking down at the the heater.
It's right underneath her. She
lives in Toronto. It's cold as fuck.
Pull the picture up Brian. It's
hilarious. It's slash lien on Twitter.
How did you find out about this
girl? Uh, somebody tweeted her,
so she's got 71,000 followers now
and she's not like a famous person.
Look at that.
Just got it.
She shows a picture of her buzzy above
the heat or she's just a funny girl.
She says a lot of funny shit.
Yeah, it's good. It's, it proves that
it works. Chris Carmona he reads,
writes a lot of funny tweets
and people, uh, you know,
you just start noticing after a
while someone forwards it to you.
She had a great joke about blowing a guy,
um,
who like blowing so many drunks that
she didn't pass her, uh, her breath,
the test breadth detector tests cause
she had sucked the drunk guys deck.
It was really funny man.
I love it when somebody like
that, you know, I always,
I've said this a million times, but like
I don't mind giving jealous when people,
you know,
have early success in size.
We have to remember the people
that aren't doing it anymore.
But I also tried to turn the jealousy
in a motivation as opposed to like
bitterness, you know, just try
to like get, okay, that's cool.
You get a little jealous and then think,
what could I be fucking doing
says here, no matter what the
letters are all knuckle tattoos.
Say Dad's gone.
That's so rude.
Just accidentally stabbed
my face on a dick.
A true friend will tell you when your
yoga pants are sucking your pussy lips up
like a three toed sloth.
It's a funny fucking Twitter page
and she does it all the time.
If you look at it, you know every
couple of days she bangs out a good one.
So like her,
her like numbers,
like she'll like take a couple
of days off or something.
But the numbers that
she puts like what she,
whatever she puts out there
is like really high quality.
She doesn't have a lot of stupid tweets
like my mind is a lot of useless tweets.
I mean some of them are funny and some
weed everyday shit. Pretty much. Yeah.
If I find anything,
I mean I'll take days off if I
find things that are interesting.
I think it's my duty almost to like
retweet things I think are interesting.
He got like 1.5 million followers
and someone comes along and shows you
something that you think other people
be interested in. It's your duty to send
it out. Like hey check this
out. Like they're your friends.
Like that's what I would do with you.
That's a great way to look at it.
If you've got an interest,
like if sort of like modeling whatever,
clays fucking making sculpture, whatever
the fuck it would be, sail boating.
And I said, Oh Todd, like sail boating.
It's a cool article on sail boating. Boom.
I would send it to you. If you were into
science. Boom, I would send it to you.
That's what you're doing on Twitter. Like
someone sends you something that makes,
you know, you go whoa. So you're
sending it to all your friends.
You know all those people on
Twitter that are your followers.
It's ironic that the, they're your
followers, you know, they follow the,
you really should probably
call him a Twitter friends.
That'd be like a nicer way. It
might be a little warmer. It's,
but it's really what it is. You know?
Why are they following me? Yeah.
Fuck you father time and
you're not my real dad.
Human to hire somebody to write funny
tweets for me. Why not? Fuck it.
Anybody can I tell you when
they correct me on spelling,
I want to have a God damn.
I want to find the person.
And I don't want to do what I want to
do because I have to calm down before I
started doing what I want. I want to
talk to them at the end of the day,
but I want to go, what is wrong
with you? Seriously? Who are you?
That's what I want to look at. Someone
to go, who are you? You read that?
I'm not going to yell at you. I'm
just going to, when you read it,
you saw there's a spelling mistake is
really that you were motivated to fix.
Re who are you?
Are you seriously like,
it sounds silly. I get it, but then
there's also like, yeah, who are they?
Who are you? What do you do to everyone
else in your life? If that's what you,
the first thing, I'm trying to be funny,
I'm a comedian. I'm not a good speller,
but your goal is good.
It was people are angry.
They're angry.
Todd glass life is not what they wanted
it to be. Well, let's say they said this,
we're trying to help.
I still go, all right.
Now you're just making
yourself the victim.
There's a lot of that that you know
what there is, there's paths, there's,
there's ways you manage
your life in this pass.
He'd go down and if you go down
that I'm a victim path by instinct,
by automatic reflexively. A lot of people
do. Goddamn those people are annoying.
Those people are so fucking annoying.
It's a real problem.
I tend to agree with you on most of
the things you say. You know, I'm,
I'm in always in a pretty
have the same area.
Sometimes you say it in a better way
than I say so it still helps to listen to
it cause I, it helps me
fight the fight. So I,
I think preaching to the choir as good.
I don't think it's a waste of time.
We're doing a fingers that move the
presales folks listening to this.
I think sometimes it's good to hear
it because you, it's like I said,
it hit it from another perspective.
I'll drop an analogy I use.
If someone gives me a better one, I'm
like, oh, that's better. Mine's gone.
I love that one.
I think we naturally would just,
we were talking about cults earlier and,
and you know, people arguing
over ideologies. I think
we naturally form tribes,
you know,
and I think there's some tribes are
formed just based on behavior and belief
systems and geography. And we get
these weird things and very dangerous.
You might think,
I swear to you,
I think this genuinely has
to do with what we're about.
I'm not trying to go cheap segue.
If I am, you'll know from my gut.
I didn't think I was,
I believe you 100%.
The only thing I wrote down and I
wanted to talk to you about was, uh,
it's not here anymore, was the when
people, you said they will need the,
you said they will form tribes. People
will just say so. Okay, here we go.
So podcasting is original, basically
taking radio and making it as, you know,
just getting rid of the middle
management. It's just, it's pure stand up.
So that's what it is.
It's getting rid of that person.
So there's this thing that happened by,
I think if you're right that people
will naturally create their own rules.
So we got rid of the person
that you just do what you want.
And then there became the was Yolie do
an hour podcast by people that did bod
test. They decided that and
I felt a little bit of that.
Now should I only do it and then you, this
is why I'm thanking you. If someone go,
oh no, Joe Rogan, he does a three hour
podcasts. I'm like thank fucking God.
Cause it was like, yeah, like I want
to do three hours, leave me to so,
but that whole rule was made by the,
here's this great institution,
get rid of all the business radio. It's a
great tool. Get rid of all the business.
Get rid of anyone telling you what to do.
It's just us now.
And someone decided to go,
yeah, you only do it as an hour.
Here's one thing I want to put out
there too. This is really important.
You don't have to do commercials in the
middle. You fucking podcast. You don't,
I don't do it. I won't do
it. I never will do it.
I'm not interrupting the fucking show
because it's brutal. It's brutal. It,
it fucks with the conversation. It puts
a hitch in the conversation and you,
we've Umaine yourself
afterwards in post here,
but if you interrupt the conversations,
start reading off a page,
we're starting from scratch again.
Certainly.
We've certainly heard good people that
had to do it when they had radio do it
and it's not the best part of it, but we
still love them. They don't have to do,
he knew more. Now you don't have
to do that. So I totally, yeah,
since you don't have to do it is because
if you are selling things that you
actually believe in, we have a series
of different products that we agree to,
but we've turned down a lot of products.
I'm like, I have no use for that.
I wouldn't use that in real life.
I don't agree with it.
I don't like what it is
that I've turned down.
Podcast sponsorships to promote
things that I don't believe in.
Movies that aren't believing
shows that I don't believe in.
Once you make that sort of an agreement,
well,
people will support the things that
support your show automatically.
They would want to, if it really is a
good product. Who is that? That's me.
God dammit.
You see that?
You know what that has pitches with this
is is a Samsung Galaxy note three that
I'm super happy with. Oh my
goodness. How do I reject,
reject a call with a message?
Okay. Hmm. Sorry, I'm busy.
Call back later.
I just sent a message.
You know what? You know what
I always think of when we're,
when I'm having conversations like this,
it's beautiful silence the size
of this thing. Folks at home,
it's going to let you
know I'm 100% android now,
fully converted and not just fully
converted, committed. Love it.
It's amazing and it's great. Is
it okay in your pocket? Yes. Yeah,
it fits in my back pocket.
I had his contact. It's a
Google phone, unfortunately.
So you have your phone contacts.
Get confused with Google.
That was the only the issue.
The only issue I've had at all was
just merely transferring my, that's
it. Everything else has been great. This
is Courtney on this thing is amazing.
There's two things. I'll figure
that out. There's a program, sorry,
because when there's a program, um,
called a smooth sync for Icloud,
couldn't be pulls it right over seizing
it takes three seconds cause I'm super
happy with this. The um, the
camera's a little wooded.
We got off the air and you go,
it's a piece of shit they're inducing.
This is just so much stuff you can do
with these things that an iPhone would
never let you do.
There's so much weird shit that
you can get done with these things.
It's that thing big and too big though
to carry around in your pants. No.
You know what's not big of, it's just
a matter of getting use it. Look,
I have a magazine that I choose on my own.
I choose all the content
and scroll through it every
day and it gives me stories
based on interesting shit. It comes
standard with the phone. There's a you,
it's so easy to cut and paste
images and put them in a scrapbook,
cut and paste URLs, save websites.
You save documents on it,
you can actually download and save things,
which the I to phone never lets you do.
You're not allowed to
download things on the iPhone.
Just put them in a file and this,
you could put it,
put things in files when
you want to play music.
He just grabbed the music and drag
it in there. It takes three seconds.
You'd have to load iTunes or anything
weird like that. It's way more.
It gives you way more freedom
in a lot of ways. That's bad.
And for some people it's
probably not what they want.
They want something that just works,
you know?
But if you're a person like me that's
like really into technology and finds it
fascinating to fuck around with new
things, you can't beat that screen son.
That's gigantic. When you go and
watch read websites on this, it's,
it's almost like a laptop iPad.
Why would I want it when I have
this in my pocket? Super Big.
It seems so easy to use. It's
easy. It fits right in my pocket.
It seems bigger than it really is.
I mean it is.
It's big to the point where it's not
like sitting on my fucking shirt here.
It's big to the point where like
if you had it in your pocket,
you wouldn't want to sit down.
He wouldn't want to sit down
like this with no my back pocket.
But if I'm just like walking around,
it fits fine. This is huge. It is huge.
But it fits the difference being to
me. First of all, it's fascinating.
I like fucking around with the new
operating system. I like playing with it.
Everything seems to work real easy.
The processors,
the fucking pictures are incredible.
The pictures,
this thing takes their magical, I mean
it's just, I don't know, what is it,
12 megapixel or something by the way,
actually funny cause I know
just gracefully happen,
but we're talking about
I would never do it.
The sponsor and then I know you're
feeling like that's not a sponsor. No,
no it's not. This cell phone isn't
sponsored me. No, that's what I mean.
Sometimes like in life I'll say something,
I will be so passionate about something
like you are and I go, there's no way.
If that was they film that they could
ever play that because there's no fucking
way anybody would believe that
was real. But it is. I'm like,
there's some product I'm talking about.
I go off on how good it is,
how could nobody have it?
And then I think there's no
way someone would believe that.
But that's how passionate I am.
But I believe you because I
know that you wouldn't do that.
But there's some people that you know
would, where some people, you know,
it's sneak in a commercial and pretend
that they really love their galaxy note
phone and it's really just a commercial.
Somebody in a silly person.
Yeah. But the, you know, the,
the idea of commercials interrupting
things is unnecessary and it's not just
unnecessary. It's not good for the
product. It's not good for the experience.
Just get good sponsors, play it in
the beginning, played at the end.
Say thank you to your sponsors.
Let everybody know those your sponsors.
We've had a lot of like really loyal
sponsors like Ting and Squarespace and as,
because we'll mention them even when
we're not doing a commercial, it's,
we really do believe,
I really believe in Squarespace.
Somebody who might be one of the ads for
this show, but they're fucking great.
It's a beautiful design.
It's a great way to make websites.
If I find something cool,
I would let you know,
even if it's not paying me money to let,
yeah.
You know how it's, um, you know,
we always guess what we would do,
what we wouldn't do it.
I know it's always a hypothetical when
you turn down because you can act morally
on your high ground when you turned down
something that wasn't offered to you.
But I you, we do it all the time.
We all may pretend as Comedians,
would you do this?
Would you do that?
And I wouldn't do Batman fucking
mainstream comic book movie. You know,
and you don't know until those things
are put ahead of you until those things
are put in front of you. And the
first one. Now granted I'm trying to,
I'm not saying I'm a,
I turned down some shit ton of money,
but at least it was an example when I
did stick to my instincts of don't do
something bad.
I learned the copy for this phone thing
and then I remember the next day waking
up and going, look again, I, you know,
how much I would've made it a new sponsor
who received a check for $50 maybe.
I don't know what we get, but, um,
I didn't understand it was one of those
ones that I hate and I go, you can't.
So I, I was afraid that they were going
to be like, oh no, you have to do it.
I called back, I'm Katie at the
time and when Katie, I, that's,
I don't even fucking understand this. And
it's like, I don't want it. She was, oh,
you don't have to do it. I
was like, oh, cool. Yeah,
I didn't know if there was
there supporting us now, but
they were like, no, no, no,
no, no. So that really
made me happy. Yeah,
it's nice. And you can also,
people will, will gravitate.
Like there's been a few people that
we've talked about their products, uh,
on the show where they've
never been sponsored,
but people know about it because of us.
And I just want people to know about that.
Like that Green Mountain Grill guy
that has those pellet grills. Great.
Greg gave us his, he doesn't pay us, he
gave us these grills and he's like, look,
I think,
just think these things are amazing.
And I would love to sponsor the podcast.
It didn't work out.
He doesn't sponsor the podcast,
but they're so cool.
I got to tell people about him.
I would always tell people about him,
whether it was a sponsor or not.
You could cook something,
one of these fucking things
for like hours at a time.
They use pellets like hardwood pellets,
a called pellet grills.
It's like a new thing. Oh, it's
the temperature stays exact.
So like if you want to
cook a roast outside,
like smokey hardwood and cook it for
like 300 degrees for like four hours or
something like that. You do that.
You just said it. It's amazing.
I didn't know that there were pellet
grills because my parents live in an old
home in Philadelphia and they had a
pellet stove in the living room and that
would come in bags and they're like
wooden and they're very natural.
It's very compressed hardwoods, natural
sugar. It looked like rabbit a little bit.
It does.
It looks like that kind of cat
litter I use to get the green stuff.
Do you use that stuff? That pine
stuff's good. It's the best stuff.
And kills the smell of the best.
Yeah. How many do you have a,
how many cats do you have to,
to what are they just cats or they have,
one of them is a rag doll cat. No one
tells are these there? He'd go limp.
When you pick them up, they're
like real sweet. Oh really? Yeah.
And the other one is, she's part per,
she's a Mutt. She's part Persian and part,
uh, like Tomcat. She's like 16
years old. She's 16 years old.
She acts like she's a kitten. It's
crazy. She says, totally healthy.
Come when you come home,
she talks to you like,
my whole house thinks it's hilarious. Just
have conversations with this cap. What?
Sometimes it's annoying. I'm not going
to lie, but you know, she cool cat.
My friend Andrew is my friend. Andrea
has a cat. And um, it, it's crazy.
Not only does it,
which I've seen a lot when you know,
like you go into someone's house,
I like if a cat jumps up
on the sofa next to me, so,
but it eats potato chips. Whatever you're
eating wants to eat. And it fetches.
So I'm like, are you shitting me? I
used to have a cat that fetches, see,
I would if to me, if you're home alone
and you have a dog or cat, anything,
just to have it,
it just,
it is a bonus when you get patches because
it's like you can do something in the
potato chips because it's like you're
maybe your home by yourself and you're
just sitting there and I,
the fact that this other thing wants
something and you give it one of the beats
it, you don't give it too much
of it. This cat hated everybody.
But me though it was great
because it fest it fetch balls.
They take a little ball of paper and
crumple it up in a ball, toss it,
and would chase after and swat it and
it would bring it back to me and then I
would throw it again. We would play
games, but she hated everybody but me,
she hissed at me when I
saw her in the pet store,
like all the other kittens were in
this little pet store and she just like
history. I was like, oh, give me
that one. Really like, she's crazy.
That's the one that needs,
well, not just that. It's like,
no, no, no, no. I'm always been akin to
the wilder creed. You don't have a dog.
You have two dogs. What do you,
was it the dog's doing a, she blew,
he knew English bulldog
mix and I'm a massive,
oh, you have a master that's, yeah.
The other one, I'm not sure what it is,
but a master of, into it there. Yeah. He's
a, he's a small, massive, he's 140 pounds,
so it's called a regency
mastiff. They, uh,
it's half Neapolitan mastiff
and they breed them with
pit bulls to make this dog.
It's like a really athletic, massive,
but they, uh, they're, they, they're big.
It's a big, like 140 pound dog,
but it moves like a panther.
It's crazy how fast these things are and
how powerful they are. But super sweet.
The sweetest dog.
I got him for his personality.
His Dad was on fear factor and uh,
I couldn't believe how sweet that dog was.
We would use him as an attack dog.
We'd put people in the suits and
he would send them out to attack.
But to the dog, it was just a game.
Like he wasn't mean to people at all,
but when the owner told him what to do,
that was the game was to go do it.
And then you've got rewarded for that.
So we put these people in these giant
attack suits and this dog just grabbed
them and boom, threw him to
the ground. But was mean like
when it was over. Well, you okay
out? He stops. He backs up and I go,
how was his dog? So cool? He goes, I don't
let the assholes breed. He goes, I just,
I make sure that all my dogs,
they never have any dog aggression.
They never have any people aggression.
So this dog was just chilling
with all these other dogs. He's a,
it looks like a lion, like this black lion
and it's just sitting there, chit his,
he was even bigger. He was 190
pounds. His father was very big,
but he's just sitting there and I'm like,
why is that dog so nice?
Like this doesn't even make sense.
Everybody would come by.
He would like look at you twice.
That's why I remember my mom bred
dogs when we were growing up. And uh,
not, not like a puppy Miller. And uh,
she said that when dogs bite out of fear,
they're not going to bite when
something really happens anyway.
It was mean that somebody takes a shovel
and lifts it up in the air where their
hand, those dogs cower. So the dogs that
are trained from like it, same thing.
Like what you're saying, my friend's a
cop and to see the dog, how calm it is.
Like, I know what that dog's capable
of and then it's so super confident.
It doesn't bite out of fear. Exactly.
Doesn't bite at a fear, you know
these mastiffs it's one of the reasons
why there's such great dogs because
they're really like relaxed
and calm around people that
hadn't worried about you.
What are you going to do? Like unless
you have a gun, what are you going to do?
Two, 190 pound mass stuff.
Not a lot, man. There's not,
this isn't going to take long.
You know,
they listened to us out of love and you
know when you have a dog that you race
from a puppy and really love this guy,
his name is Joe and he has this, uh, this,
I mean he doesn't, he doesn't have a
puppy mill at all. He has the opposite.
Like he re they're called regency
mastiffs and it's a breed that he created
himself that he's been
working on for like decades.
And so he's like super specific
about what dogs he lets breed.
And at the end of the day,
he has this amazing companion
like this Johnny, Johnny,
Johnny Cash is my dog. He's the sweetest
dog I've ever had in my life. I mean,
he's just a gentle, big giant
who's just, he loves everybody.
He loves my three year old. He loves
my five year old, loves other kids,
other kids come over.
He's immediately like happy.
He doesn't get weird around them. He's
like super. Any friend that comes over,
you've met Johnny. He's super
friendly. Right? Like immediately.
You don't feel sketched out by him at
all. Right? Right. No, I love your dogs.
Both of them. Yeah. But and booboos very
sweet too. They're all sweet dogs. Yeah.
You know,
one time I used to,
I was about five years ago watching a
friend's dog and I saw one day in the
street what the dog did to another day.
He went, I've never seen him like that,
that type of aggression towards
another door. Nothing happened.
I had him on his leash, but
I was like, I never saw it.
And I remember thinking it was the
type of dog that when I had him,
I would bite his face and just
love them and buying them.
And I thought I'd be afraid to do that
now. But guess what? But that night I did,
I was like, cause he was so like I go,
that's a different, and I'm a chicken,
I'm a chicken.
But I just,
I get it when people are comfortable
around animals because they'll sense it.
Cause I don't know why I just thought no,
he's that way with that dog.
So I'm like going back to biting him.
Sawso
probably protecting you.
He doesn't trust that dog.
He doesn't know why that dogs near him.
That dog is violating his territory
by being a stranger in near him
instinctively.
So unless he's socialized,
unless you take them around
other dogs all the time,
it's a natural instinct to
want to ward off other dogs.
That's why I'm raising a dog.
You could raise a dog that's really
sweet with people, which my dogs were.
But then we have real problems with
other dogs, especially if it's genetic,
like pit bulls or something
along those lines. I've seen it.
There's no way you can avoid it.
You can't avoid it.
The only thing you could do is socialize
those dogs and bring them around a lot
of other dogs and constantly
reprimand them or stop them from, uh,
from attacking and stopped
them and keep them exercised.
You got to wear them out,
like throw the ball with them having
play and only like make it a positive
experience when they meet other dogs.
But still you could run into some other
dog that tests them and next thing you
know, they're going at it. But
they don't have that to you though.
Like all my dogs that I've ever had,
whether they had problems
with other dogs or not,
they've all been sweet to people.
All of them.
They just can't wait to jump up and
kiss people because that's all they get.
All they get is sweetness at home. You
know, they get, hey, don't eat that. Hey,
don't chew that no bad. But they don't
get beat up. They don't get yelled at.
They get kissed and hugged.
And when you have an animal like that,
you were saying the, uh, you know, there,
when they get around other
animals that they've been seen.
That's why a long time ago
I made this rule like, oh,
it'd be like a bunch of us running
maybe a house up in lake arrowhead or
something and where people
go, hey, can we bring the dog?
And then I would trust them. They will go,
he's, oh no, he's so calm. He's so calm.
But then someone else would
ask and if there were two dogs,
they weren't they and they
would all apologize all weekend.
They're not normally like that.
I know, but they are here.
You're bringing them around fighting
or even if it's not somebody,
even if their dogs calm at home,
sometimes it can not be common another
place because it's not comfortable.
There's noises. So I'm not mad at the dog,
but I'm like, there's always exceptions.
I get it. But overall, my feeling is
there are exceptions, but overall,
leave your dog. I totally agree. I've
brought my dog places and it's selfish.
It's selfish. I was selfish when
I did it. And people who do it,
they don't think they're being
selfish. But I mean, you could do it.
Like if it's one of my friend's dogs and
I love the dog and I've been around the
dog a lot, and I don't
mind, that's one thing,
but a lot of times the dog dominates your
thinking. Now that dog, where's the dog?
There's a dog in the kitchen. The dog,
the dog in my bathroom, my bathroom man,
when we went camping, Eh, not even
from, I wasn't crazy that these people,
by the way,
you know why I always say there's always
exceptions because I live a very parent.
Maybe it's not a paranoid life,
but I've had dogs where people bring them
and I'm happy they brought their house.
Of course, I even ask I who know, bring
your dog, bring your dog. So there's,
but over all, you got to test the
waters a little. You know what I mean?
I don't want anybody that I would think
that would listen and I, and I'd be like,
no, no. You were talking. I really did.
Like, I'm not just making exceptions,
but overall leave your dog at home.
Yeah.
Overall unless you have an understanding,
right.
Like each other. Like I have my friend
Robbie, when I first got my dog,
he had a dog, there was a boxer
and him and my dog were like,
they would get together and they're
both basically the same age.
I think his dogs are a little bit older
and they would just go fucking nutty,
just run around in circles and bounce
up in the air. When they saw each other,
they were so excited
because they were pals.
Like they had decided to like
really early on they, they
play font and stuff like that.
But they were buddies.
So when they were around each
other, they're like, holy shit,
I can't believe you're here. Woo. And they
would just start bouncing and jumping.
And it was fun. It was, but we
had to watch them. You know,
we had to watch them every five seconds.
You forget about those two type of dog
cause you're right. On the most part,
you're lucky if they're just
don't care about each other.
But when they get along.
Yeah, it is like too,
I remember growing up we had our friend's
parents who would bring their dog over
and you could just tell they were like
in the yard and getting along and like,
just look at them. They're friends. Yeah.
It's cool when, when dogs are buddies,
you know, it's cool when
they, they, they, they,
you know that's in dogs are pack
animals too. That's the other thing.
Dogs want to be around other dogs.
Like they love being around people,
but they also love being around dogs. Like
to leave a dog by itself all the time.
It's kind of sad. It gets lonely,
you know? Yeah. You're your dog.
Selfish Bitch Paul Little Dog. No, I'm
pretty good except for Monday, sir. Hey,
how long you got to do what you gotta do
you ever have somebody, they'll go like,
how long can you, what do you think the,
the reasonable amount of time on it?
Five days a week to leave your
dog at home alone is, well,
five days a week. It's not,
the house is tough. Um, let's,
so we can be just so we can, let's
save doggy door to a yard. Oh wait, no.
That widens it a lot. That makes a big
diverse and I'm thinking of no, no. Uh,
no Doggie door is potty trained on IPADS.
Well that's pretty, it sounds
good on paper. What it is,
is these paper towels with shit on
him in your house? Yeah. It's fucking,
it's fucking disgusting.
I know that this potty trained,
he only shifts all over the place.
They're gross beyond gross.
But the worst is like my old dog used
to just go when I had carpet would piss
and you would never know about it.
And then so when we tore up the
carpet it was just like, oh my God.
How much pissed it might've been. Your
cat shits all over the place. Your dog,
your cat pissed a lot. Yeah.
Yeah. Especially the cat.
The cat is upset that
you live with a dog now.
Like you brought a dog into the
cat's house and catch a cause.
The bitch piss everywhere.
You're not even here.
You mother fucker must treat this thing
like I would treat it like they did.
They totally decided that there's like,
I haven't seen that guy in 10 hours.
I'm just going to piss like
what would I do in the wild?
They're just piss right here.
So that's what they started doing.
The litter box stinks.
He doesn't clean it.
I'm just pissed behind a couch over
here, that smell refrigerator. Hey,
they want to be, they want to be treated
right. My cats don't piss in the house.
You know when my cat was
pissing in the house,
when I would change the litter box,
like every couple of days,
I would change it like every three or
four days and she would pee in front of
the door. Sometimes. The old one, you
can't yell at her. She's 16 but I'm like,
what are you stupid bitch? Like what
are you doing? Like pissing in my house.
And then I realized,
you know why she only does that if
the litter box is kind of funky.
So now that I clean it every single day,
she never does that stopped, you know,
they don't want to do that.
You just dirty bitch.
He had a fucking big box at shit.
She preaching step in.
You know what I was thinking if let's
say you had a cat and you had like,
well you know what, what I'm about
to say? Probably we could afford it.
Let's say it was $3,500 a
Wa a hard plumbed cat box. Hard plumbed
meaning that's what they call it. Like,
like if you have like a,
some people like take their trailer
and they put it next to their home and
sometimes they use it as a guest house
or they, I heard a plumber wants to go,
your heart plummet, which means you hook
it up to the regular sewage. Right, right.
So if you had a heart, like
a toilet, but it's a cat box,
wouldn't it be great in New York?
That's very possible.
Typically it's like a little toilet.
Maybe there's some sort of litter that
way you never have to change your cat box.
You just flush it. Yeah. But it doesn't
seem like the Cabbie down with that.
They want to shit and dirt. Dana, what
if you put dirt in their toilet? Yeah,
there was cats.
If you can do that,
but doesn't she have one of those
big crazy sphinx cats or something?
Or she has the skinless cats. Yeah, that's
what I mean. It's just thanks Kat. It,
yeah. Forgot about to go in the toilet.
Maybe my whole idea is not a good one.
Well, they do do that. There's
a, yeah, she has a sphynx cat.
I'm pretty sure that's the
hairless one. There is. Um,
I've seen pictures of it
on Twitter. There's a, um,
a bunch of people that have
videos and how to train your cat.
That shit in the toilet. Yeah. I didn't
trust, wasn't thinking. See, look,
here's that. Dane is
doing it. That's so crazy,
dude. What is going on inside
that toilet besides the p?
I think that's the training. That's
the training thing, you know? Oh,
to teach the cat how to be in
there. Oh, that makes sense. Oh,
maybe she gets a treat. Oh, that's
so smart. That's really smart.
What Kulak and cat. It's an
alien. It's cancer. Awesome.
And if you're allergic to cats,
these cats don't have dander.
So you can actually have this as a cat.
Yeah. Are they supposed to be sweet? Yes.
Supposed to be cuddly. Cars are
amazing. They need body temperature.
They need body heat. So they want to
snuggle with you all the time. Yeah,
she's always taking bath.
That's why they bred the,
I would imagine like there was no really
reason to breed the standard poodle to
the golden retriever or Labrador,
except that they,
they know that they're big cool dogs.
But people wouldn't want
it cause it's a poodle.
I think maybe because we had a standard
poodle growing up and then when we were
little, we didn't want to get it. My
parents had to lie what they were,
cause we wouldn't want a poodle. Why not?
Because it's not cool. It's not cool.
But my mom said, dog, did you
want a lab? Anything but a poodle.
Like we were little and
we took it to this place.
I remember it was like this woman Ruth
Lukens and it was immaculate and it was
like a woman that really loves her literal
puppies she had and they came running
out and we loved them.
We were,
it was probably like in
fifth grade or fourth grade,
my brothers all about the same
age and we all, they were so cool.
And then we had to learn that they were
eventually standard poodle and we got
one Billy and then bear and they were big.
Like there was like 90 pounds,
a hundred and almost close to a hundred
pounds. He was a big mail, but now,
but labradoodle isn't sending any cooler.
Well it's a thing like a combination
thing that people like is thing too.
They love saying it and social circles.
Oh, he's got a labradoodle. I love those.
Have you seen those? They're so cute. It
becomes one of those and they don't shed.
That's the thing. Oh that's the
reason I picked the standard poodle.
You'd get the dog, it doesn't
shed. They're smart. And then they,
that actually sounds really good.
That sounds like a good dog.
They're pretty smart. I like smart dogs,
but here's the deal with smart dogs,
you got to give them things to
do. Okay. That type of smart.
If you have a German shepard,
like people have German shepherds and
they don't exercise them and they don't,
they don't give them tasks and have
fun with them and play with them.
If you don't do that,
that thing's going to get bored as fuck.
And that's a big ass animal. And how
many people do you think go with the,
with the technology,
with the H,
how easy it is to do a little
research on a dog and find that out.
I bet there's so many people that get it,
like they're there at the time in their
life when they don't think about it,
which I understand they're going to
go get a dog now. Some people do,
but other people wouldn't. And
just get a dog. They have no idea.
No one ever told him that huskies.
So they just get a husky and then
they learn like, you know what I mean?
Like now I can see that 40 years ago,
but now you would think you would,
but there's still people.
I have friends that got a Husky
Friends of friends and they were to I,
we were camping and they
told the story and I'm like,
oh they had no idea they went and just
got a husky. What does this video, right.
You know,
like by the way,
do I take that for granted or did you
know huskies or they want to be working.
So if they're not,
they do destruction.
Is that something that most
people know I was true today?
Most people would know that. Fuck up.
You're a little dig out your yard.
Yeah.
Mike,
this guy just said lets his German
shepard play with his bare notice I said
Brenda friends, I didn't want you to
think all my friends were idiots. Yeah,
look at this. Bear sends a great video.
Have you seen this video Jeff? Oh,
it's amazing guys. Buddies with a bear
and the dog hangs out with the bear too.
Yeah,
well that's all well and good.
As long as the bear really super likes
you and you were with it all the time.
That's the thing about those things,
kind of be with them all the fucking time,
man.
You gotta make sure they're well fed,
you've got to make sure that they're
super comfortable with you and yet still
those bears will eventually, you know,
occasionally rather turn on people.
I agree. You know, it's funny when
we, you know, I always, this is my,
my obsession with life and
I always see examples of it.
Every time I see something
now I see an example.
There's some people that would think
putting a horn in that I agree by the way.
Like just try to have some dignity
to the animal. The San Diego Zoo,
you used to be able to keep in mind,
it's still a zoo.
So that's the bigger argument.
But when we were little,
I learned this when we went back.
They don't make them clap their hands
anymore and wave to you, the bears.
And I asked why. Because when,
once, when I went with my parents,
they did when we were younger.
Then when I was an adult and I went,
they didn't do it.
And the pita said [inaudible] well,
they already don't want them at
the zoo now. Well they're there.
Can you give some dignity? Does, does
that make that makes sense to me.
It makes sense to me. Um, that you, uh,
if you're going to a zoo, first of all,
you should see an animal in
a semi natural environment.
I think zoos should have a minimum
size requirement for big animals.
The saddest things.
When you see like a big animal and they
were in a tiny ass fucking enclosure,
that's scary. You know, that's,
it's a prison, a public prison.
Everyone you would agree to to.
So even if the animal's happy,
it looks like it's happy doing it.
There's no reason to make him no reason,
no reason to make fake trumpet. Here's my
question. Who Fuck wants to see it? Clap.
Why do you want to see a bear
clap? You fucking Weirdo.
It's a bear. You know what?
Want to see a bear.
You should see that bear wandering around
the woods and its natural environment.
Anything else? It's human beings
imposing their own power over this
animal. And then all the
crowd reveling in the fact
bear just clapped on its own.
Who would give a fuck?
It's the idea that you tell the bear to
clap and look the big giant furry killer,
but goes to the bidding of the
intelligent man. Yay, we win again.
That's what the celebration is.
And everybody cheers at seaworld cause
you've got this majestic fucking Orca.
So the reason to jump for fish,
the reason that I think this is
what happens a lot with people.
And you know what? When I always
talk about this, I always think,
am I saying I'm perfect? No, but I
hope I fucking grow. I tried to be,
you're being honest about
your opinions on things,
but not saying that you're perfect.
I'm not saying I'm perfect,
but it could sound like it.
I guess if you listen to someone
for a while thinking, oh he's a try,
I fucking at least try
and I make mistakes.
So the question isn't that
people when they go to sea world,
cause I think a lot of people go this I
just went and I didn't think, no, no, no.
We're not asking you to judge yourself
when, when you went, when you went,
that's who gives. You didn't think about
it. Now, once you're educated, right,
I went to sea world. I didn't think
about it. I wasn't a bad person.
I'm not going to hold on to the rest of
my life that it's okay cause I did it.
Cause if I admit that it's wrong,
I admit I did something wrong. No,
it's not wrong until you have knowledge.
Right. So that's what the seaworld thing,
going back to that or this, the
Peta, you know the same people.
We're probably going,
oh they're just waving.
But Nah, now you think about, do you want
that fucking bear to ride a bike? Yeah.
And I watched it the first time and
liked it, but I was young. I didn't know.
But you have to ride a bike.
It's one thing if you have a bear and you
teach that or ride a bike and it loves
it and it's like, where's
the bike? You know?
But when you're making them do it for
a fucking show, you know, it's like,
come on man. Yeah. When you think about
it, and again, I went to video, I'm sorry,
but did you ever see the
video of the bears and monkeys
and they're going around,
they're riding bikes around a circle in
Russia and the monkey falls and the bear
attacks it and they can't
get the bear off the monkey.
The bear kills the monkey
in front of the crowd.
Do you ever see that bear bear attacks?
Monkey?
Can I take, why do I
think, although I know my,
I wouldn't want my child to see that so,
but my instincts were to go good.
Well He,
you can't count on bears to do what you
want to do all the time that you can
count on them if you train
them to be nice to you,
if you feed them and train them,
you could count it.
But that is a wild motherfucking animal
with a hair trigger idea of survival and
death built into its DNA and it's ready
to explode at any fucking dangerous
situation.
And if it thinks a person is threatening
it's life or if it thinks something is
violating its instincts to avoid, look
at this bear. The bear is on a bike.
Yeah,
the monkey see the monkeys in front.
The monkeys in front of the bear scooted
ahead a little bit cause it might take
a few minutes.
So the uh,
monkeys running and then the bears
running with the monkey falls and the bear
falls on top of the monkey and gets pissed
and just goes after the monkey there.
These are tearing the monkey apart in
front of everybody and they can't get them
off the monkey. They're like,
stop, please stop. Please stop.
They're pulling the monkey.
They're pulling the bike in.
The bear is just fucking this monkey up.
It's a big bear and they can't do shit.
They're trying to pull the monkey out
of his hands are out of its mouth,
but it won't let go.
It's just mauling this monkey in
front of everybody freaking out.
But that's nature, man. This bear feels
like he'd got attacked by the Monkey.
The bear is not understanding that he
was on a bike and the monkey was on bike.
Now they pulled the monkey out,
but it's dead
parks than monkey is just
minding his own business doing.
Everybody tells him to do, but the bear
thinks that the monkey attacked him.
He doesn't. He knows what
he's like, why did I get hurt?
All this fucking monkey like you get
attacked me and so he just goes after him.
I think I feel good when
I see it obviously not
because of the monkey cause I
think.
Oh okay. Maybe that will
remind people. Yeah,
they're fucking bears the same old thing.
We think every time we see that stuff,
that's a county thing to do to take
an animal and in prison it like that.
It's not a bad thing to do.
Look at them in the wild.
It's not a bad thing to do to manage
their numbers in the while and including
like wolves and bears and you got
to kill a certain amount of them,
especially if there's a
lot of people in the area.
You have to keep populations down.
It's important mountain lions too.
It's a big one, but there's, there's,
that to me is not nearly as cruel.
It's taken them and sticking them in a
fucking animal prison so we can gawk at
him. That shit should be illegal.
I take my kids to the zoo,
but I want to say right now
I'm a hypocrite. Take them
to the Santa Barbara Zoo.
It's a beautiful place. I
love it up there, but the
reality is it shouldn't exist.
It shouldn't.
If the very least you should have some
gigantic walled in preserve where you
could travel through their ranks,
undisturbed like in some
sort of a camouflage tube,
but they should be able to hunt. The
animals should have a natural ecosystem.
We're completely dominating their
ecosystem and forcing them to exist in an
unnatural paradigm.
The paradigm of cold food being slid
in a tray under your door and you have
massive predatory instincts
of thousands of years,
millions of years in
fact of DNA in your body.
And you have these natural reward systems
that you uh, you don't understand.
You don't have language and context,
you just have these natural reward
systems beat in and you're told to ignore
them.
You know, you just sort of,
whether this could happen or not,
but bigger things have been built,
you sorta just explained
something that could happen.
Like there's this thing obviously with
technology to get it moved through this
area silently would be easy camouflage,
you know,
it looks like and you get inside
and there's windows that are one.
And then if there's some way you could
let all that happen and what could you
charge then to tape this thing
through their, first of all,
it'd be be much more maybe, maybe,
maybe that could be, you know,
but I liked what you said about you.
You got to go to the zoo because
like the opposite of that is, okay,
I'm going to take my kid that do.
So now I'm going to just make pretend
that it's okay. It's better to just say,
yeah, I'm doing it, but it's fun.
Certainly hypocritical because
I'm contributing to the problem.
Yeah.
And I do the same thing,
but I think admitting it is at least
not disrespecting the people that are
fighting the fight.
And we know they're right.
Like I think one thing going is bad.
The next level,
and maybe I'm saying this to make me feel
better because I get ultimately don't
go don't, but I think there's another
level of, there's people out there.
You are too lazy.
You know their fight is right.
You're a little too lazy or selfish and
you don't listen, but don't fight them.
Don't call
them idiots. Just go. They're fighting
the right fight and I'm lazy, right?
Yeah.
I'm certainly selfish.
I'm selfish more than I am lazy because
I want my children to experience these
animals.
That's why I go.
I think it's fascinating for them to
see gorillas and know that that's a real
animal right there and it freaks them out.
But seaworld, you w would you take no.
Well, I think even gorillas
and chimps, I think it's gross.
I think all that should be illegal,
but it's legal and it's there and I'm
not sure how much impact. I know this,
believe me, folks who were, who
are or you're writing right now,
she was hypocritical flock.
These animals are living beings.
I agree with you 100% but it's still
there. It's there. The zoo is there.
Do I think it should be there? Absolutely
not their thing. It should be illegal.
And should I be boycotting it?
Most likely if it was just me on my own,
I wouldn't go.
But in this situation that I am in
right now and having children who enjoy
looking at the animals,
I think it's important first of all,
that I take in there and I tell them
that there's something wrong with this.
I tell them that I don't like it.
I tell them that I think that animals
should be free to live in their own
environment and I think that
this is way worse than being,
I think an animal. I mean obviously
they wouldn't have this choice,
but if they had a choice between living
in the wild and being taken out by a
Predator or living in a fucking cage,
just staring at people that stare at you,
I would take my chances with a wolf, you
die. It's quick and it's the natural way.
This is nonsense. Giraffes are
not supposed to die of old age.
It's supposed to get taken out by lions.
All right?
That's what's supposed to happen.
It sounds fucked up,
but that's what they always
cause no one could defy that.
That's just flat out nature is what it is,
is what it is.
Cause ELLs or fast for a reason because
they taste delicious and there's a bunch
of animals that want to fucking chase him
and eat him. I mean, it's really simple.
It's really sent. But to put
them in a cage and say, oh,
this is where the judge cause L's live
now. This is crazy. They can't even run.
They're stuck in this little tiny spot
and they're freaking out and they always
think someone's going to get them,
but no one's going to get them ever.
I even feel bad for goldfish. Yeah.
Golf Fisher. Stupid as fuck though.
They barely have it. Even brains.
This bitch is winding down Todd glass.
You're an amazing mother fucker.
You're hilarious comedian. And it was,
thank God we finally did this.
Yeah. Um, this was, this was
a, I never get to do this ever.
So do this anytime you want. No,
but I mean it's like you, you know,
it's fun to do a podcast where you get
to do something you don't do in years.
And I was able to let go.
That was an amazing, uh, one
hit upon. I took her to this.
That lasted the whole time.
About 10 minutes ago.
I felt myself coming down and that was
just a very enjoyable conversation.
I really enjoyed it too. You're, you're a
very thoughtful guy and I think you, you,
uh, confused that with a over analyzing.
I think he just thoughtful. Well,
I appreciate that. I really
enjoyed talking to you, man.
We'll do this again. Cool.
All right. Todd glass. Follow him on
Twitter. It's Todd glass with two D's.
Not One d walking Weirdo.
Helium,
helium Thanksgiving week. Oh, the
club that will you help design? Yeah.
Wednesday Adelphia Wednesday
before thanksgiving. And then, uh,
take thanksgiving off and
then do a Friday and Saturday.
And then I'll be in Dallas at Addison the
second week of December of a beautiful
fucking club. Addison Improv,
one of favorite places. One of my
favorite places.
People were wild as fuck.
It proves that you can have a
comedy club in a typical strip mall,
but it has fucking soul.
Yeah. That place has salt.
That place has been around a
long time too. All right. Um,
we will be back tomorrow with Pat Mcgee.
The guy who made the Werewolf out in the
lobby. And, uh, what do you point to? Oh,
can I had to say, when did you wait till
I'm done with the fucking park. You can,
we'll get you in there,
man with don't interrupt it.
Pat Mcgee will be here tomorrow and
then, um, uh, Sam Harris on Wednesday.
So a, the return of a powerful
Sam Hannah. Sam Harris.
What a this Thursday I in San Diego,
I'll be at the American comedy company.
We're having a big Halloween party,
a show and party there.
It's just going American comedy
co.com Siobhan to surprise guests too.
And we can't even talk about it, but
huge headliner, another great club,
American comedy company.
Awesome place you go there.
I've heard great things about perfect
setup and a this weekend, Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
I'm at the Irvine Improv with lovely
and talented Tony Hinchcliffe. Alright,
you freaks. We will see you
tomorrow. And a big kiss Ma.
Okay.